[Musique]
Matur Boost, bonjour.
Salut.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
On vous reçoit en tant que sociologue.
C'est ça ? Vous êtes sociologue ?
Ouais, c'est le métier que j'ai entre
les mains. Après, ça définit pas toute
ma vie. Mais
alors, on va la définir. C'est quoi
votre vie ? Et comment on pourrait
définir votre vie ?
Non, je sais pas si on peut définir ma
vie mais en tout cas je fais de la
recherche indépendante en sciences
sociales et je fais ça depuis depuis
l'élale en y participant et et au
service au service des luttes. Du coup,
ma vie c'est pas celle d'un sociologue à
l'université ou c'est un peu sur ça que
ça se différencie. Après
en fait un vrai sociologue, pas un
sociologue de salon feutré, vous êtes un
sociologue de terrain.
Je sais pas s'il y a des vrais
sociologue mais des fois tu as un métier
entre les mains puis tu fais pas ça
toute la journée, toute la nuit, toute
ta vie et c'est c'est fait partie de mes
activités.
Pourquoi vous avez choisi de vous
intéresser à la sociologie des luttes ?
Ouais, je fais pas de la sociologie des
lutes, je fais de la sociologie du
pouvoir et du système économique,
politique, de l'impérialisme, du
colonialisme, de l'ordre sécuritaire,
mais je le fais depuis les luttes.
C'estàd j'étudie pas les luttes moi, par
exemple. Je pense que les luttes, elles
sont assez grandes justement pour pour
produire leur forme de savoir, leur
forme de savoir critique. Moi, je me
vois plutôt comme un une sorte
d'artisan. Je fabrique des outils euh
dans mon petit atelier avec d'autres
artisans, avec mes potes, avec euh avec
des gens que je pense qu'on des idées
intéressantes et puis euh bah quand on a
fabriqué un outil, on propose et les
luttes, elles s'en servent et elles
fabriquent elles-mêmes avec ses outils
leurs armes. Leurs armes. Enfin, ça ça
repose sur l'idée que chacun se libère
soi-même, on libère pas les autres et
puis qu'on se libère ensemble aussi. Et
du coup euh du coup bah les luttes, les
dominer, les opprimés et font ce que ell
et ils veulent de ces outils. Ils les
transforme, ils s'en servent pas si ça
leur sert à rien. Ils en font des choses
plus contantes, plus techniques s'il y a
besoin.
C'est quoi le dernier outil que vous
avez développé ?
Bah, je fais différentes choses. Alors,
je fabrique des enfin je fabrique Ouais,
je participe à fabriquer des bouquins.
Euh mais on fait aussi de la vidéo dans
l'idée bah justement de pouvoir parler à
tout le monde, de pouvoir être
accessible à tout le monde. Il y a des
gens qui ont le temps et l'envie euh de
lire. Euh il y a d'autres gens qui ont
ni le temps ni l'envie ou c'est pas leur
c'est pas leur c'est pas le support qui
leur qui leur parle. Euh voilà. Après,
je fais aussi, ça m'arrive de faire des
live tweet genre, j'ai passé 3 jours à
Milipol au salon de la au salon mondial
de la sécurité intérieure des États et
du coup bah j'essaie de
vous ont laissé rentrer.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. C'est pour ça que
c'est assez marrant la manière dont ils
contrôlent leur leur sécurité. Et euh
mais en fait justement c'est ça que tu
découvres aussi par exemple, c'est que
c'est qu'il y a une dimension spectacle
et ultra médiatique qui fait que qui
fait qu'ils ont besoin de montrer les
dispositifs qui mettent sur le marché et
que et que du coup ils ferment pas
complètement leur porte à ce que
différents types de médias y entrent. Et
puis en plus vu qu'ils sous-traitent à
de la sécurité privée, ils font pas non
plus énormément gaffe à qui rentre. Et
puis bon bah après je suis aussi un je
fais de la recherche comme un aussi
comme un journaliste d'investigation,
c'est-à-dire tu peux pas non plus
m'empêcher de rentrer. Vous
avez pas de carte de presse ?
Ça dépend ? Non, j'ai pas de carte de
presse mais par contre je suis comme un
je l'équivalent d'un pigiste pour
certaines certains médias sur internet
ou certaines revues et et voilà. Bah du
coup bah pour Milipol, je fais un
travail de
de mise à disposition de ce qui s'y
passe à l'intérieur quoi. Là avec du
tweet, on l'a fait aussi, je sais pas,
il y a quelques jours pour une journée
organisée par survie sur sur la
France-Afrique, sur le néocolonialisme
ou bah pour tous les gens qui sont qui
peuvent pas être présents, et ben
j'essaie de mettre à disposition les
contenus qui ont été développés pour se
faire de l'autoforation collective. Euh
voilà, pour s'organiser.
Est-ce que vous êtes fichier S ? Oui,
j'ai une fiche S. Ouais. qui a été mis
dans mon Je passe en procè en en avril
et du coup pour bien me pour bien
construire la figure de le le le chef du
syndicat Alliance euh de la police
nationale, il dit que je fais partie des
idéologues des Antiflic. Et du coup pour
bien alourdir mon dossier parce que du
coup je me suis fait tabasser par euh
par la police nationale au cœur du
commissariat central de Toulouse il y a
en 2013 et bien sûr la police pour se
couvrir comme à chaque fois qu'elle
tabasse des gens elle a porté plainte
contre moi et donc ma plainte il y a
rien du tout mais c'est moi qui passe en
avril
devant un juge pour outrage violence et
rébellion et du coup pour bien
construire la figure de de l'idéologue
antiflic ils ont mis ma fiche
dans le dans le dossier ils l'ont versé
au dossier
et et il il dans votre fichess il y a
marqué quoi ? Vous avez eu accès à cette
fiche ?
Bah j'ai accès parce qu'elle est dans le
dossier justement. Après, il y a rien
marqué d'autre que ne pas attirer
l'attention et je sais plus ce que c'est
le terme appartenance à je sais plus
s'ils disent mouvance d'ultra gauche ou
à narcoautonome, une une connerie comme
ça. Et en fait tout ce qui rentre pas
dans leur enfin tout ce qui leur résiste
et qui rentre pas dans les cadres de ce
que en général ils appellent islamistes
et ben tu te retrouves dans la catégorie
ultra gauche subversif. Il disait
subversif avant.
Quand on veut tuer son chien, on dit
qu'il a la rage.
C'est ça.
Ça vous fait quel effet d'avoir une
fichesse ?
Je sais pas, c'est un peu c'est un peu
emmerdant quand tu sors du territoire
européen parce que du coup en fait on
t'arrête à chaque passage de frontière
et
si tu en as marre et que et que tu te
soumets pas exactement à ce qu'ils
attendent et ben on te fait rater ton
avion suivant et cetera. Mais bon, pour
les pour les profils comme moi,
c'est-à-dire, enfin, je dis comme moi,
pour les en gros pour les blancs,
on t'emmerde pas beaucoup plus que ça.
Enfin, si des fois tu te fais défoncer
dans un commissariat, mais euh je veux
dire, ça a pas la même implication que
pour les fichiers S catégorisés
islamistes où là on te pourrit ta vie
familiale, ta vie au quartier où tu peux
tu peux te faire
les flics qui vous ont pas défoncé pour
rien, ils vous ont pas défouryé dans un
commissariat. Comment ça s'est passé
cette histoire là ? Et ben alors, on va
s'écarter un peu du sujet mais on
s'écarte. On va revenir sur le sujet
spécial mais ça m'intéresse. Ça
m'intéresse
ben on après, il y a différentes
analyses. Moi mon analyse et avec des
proches, c'est que mon entraîner dans un
quartier populaire du centre de Toulouse
et qui sont venus faire ce qu'ils font
en général d'habitude, c'est-à-dire
chasser. et et vu que et vu que bah on
entraînait avec des noirs et des arabes
et des jeunes de classe populaire et ben
ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont l'habitude de
faire et ce euh enfin et ça ça repose
sur le fait qu'ils sont protégés quand
ils font ça. C'estàd qu'ils peuvent se
permettre de chasser des jeunes euh de
classe populaire issus de la
colonisation et de les défoncer sans
jamais avoir aucun problème. Donc euh
donc il continuent euh et en fait quand
tu leur résistes un peu et ben ils se
lâchent complètement puisque de toute
façon ça le il y a aucune retombée sur
eux. et que bien entendu, il gère pas de
la même manière les étudiants, les
syndicalistes.
Il y a quand même des conseils de
discipline avec la police.
Ouais. En fait le si tu donc en fait tu
as des tu as des structures internes
pour les MS et la discipline. Donc eux
ils m'ont interrogén
Non, ça c'est avant l'IGPN. C'estàd au
début par exemple ma ma plainte, elle a
même pas été traitée par l'IGPN. Donc tu
es traité par ce service là. Et ce
service en fait, il fait tout euh pour
te grossir ton dossier et bien entendu
disculper les collègues. Euh et donc
bien sûr, on cherche tous les tous les
moyens de te faire passer pour un un
dangereux un dangereux tout ce qu'on
veut quoi. Et voilà, du coup la première
plainte, elle a été dite sans suite
alors que enfin je bref il y a des
photos, il y a des je suis passé devant
le la médecine légale.
Il y a eu des des jours d'incapacité de
travail ?
Ouais ouais.
60 jours au niveau médical et en fait ça
s'est transformé, on dit au titre pénal,
ça se transforme en 3 jours et c'est
l'inverse pour la police. C'estàd une
journée au sens médical, ça peut devenir
4 5 6 jours et cetera pour un policier
au sens au sens pénal. Et bon bref, et
donc ce service là, il est déjà là pour
bah protéger la maison, hein, protéger
le service. Euh et en fait du coup, bah
si tu
c'est votre interprétation. Oui, enfin
c'est aussi mon travail he c'est ça fait
aussi 15 ans que je travaille sur la
police et l'armée française et que je
fais la comparaison avec les les autres
systèmes des des grande puissance
occidental et en fait on trouve de enfin
dans tous les pays euh chaque structure
chargée du maintien de l'ordre a ses
propres services d'enquête qui lui
permettent de nettoyer ce qui la gêne
mais en général c'est plutôt les
alcooliques, des choses comme ça. C'est
pas le fait d'utiliser la violence parce
que la violence c'est le propre de la
fonction policière. C'est la police,
c'est une structure qui est chargée du
maintien de l'ordre social euh par
l'usage de la coerition.
Ça c'est notre interprétation aussi de
la police normalement,
c'est pas une interprétation. Enfin,
oui, c'est un cadre théorique d'analyse
pour protéger la population. Non,
non, ça c'est pas une interprétation. Ça
c'est le la fiction légitimante, c'est
le c'est le discours d'état, c'est le
récit d'état qui permet de légitimer le
fonctionnement de cette institution là.
C'est ce qu'on nous apprend depuis la
maternelle, que le la police, elle est
là pour protéger la veuve et l'orphelin.
Euh sauf qu'en fait, on sait exactement,
enfin ça dépend pour qui et où on vit,
mais par contre quand qu'on grandit dans
les classes populaires, dans les
quartiers populaires, on sait très bien
que en fait, s'il y a une veuve et un
orphelin qui ont un problème, la police
de toute façon elle vient pas, pas pour
ça. Euh et que en fait la police, elle
intervient ses dans ses formes
d'intervention et et de ce qu'elle
produit, ça n'a jamais rien à voir avec
la défense des habitants des quartiers
populaires. La fonction de la police
dans les quartiers populaires et ce qui
est une de ses fonctions principales,
c'est de maintenir la ségrégation, un
système d'oppression, c'est que chacun
reste bien dans sa classe social, c'est
qu'on puisse pas bouger. Et puis bah,
c'est une forme aussi de maintien de
d'un ordre, on pourrait dire, d'un socio
à partide.
Est-ce que vous avez étudié le code de
déontologie de la police nationale ?
Et oui, mais c'est c'est une blague ça.
Quand est-ce qu'il a changé ?
Mais en fait, c'est le c'est pareil, ça
fait partie d'un d'un récit
légitimement. C'estàd même on peut en
discuter même tu fais des entretiens
avec des policiers ça les fait marrer
même ils ont plutôt tendance à gueuler
sur ce trucl-là de dire c'est quoi ce
truc-là l'existence d'un code de
déontologie ça voudrait dire que on
serait pas exactement dans les pratiques
qu'on veut mais la base de la sociologie
de la police même pas mon courant à moi
parce que moi bien sûr je suis dans un
dans un courant d'analyse critique mais
même le les les courants
je peux dire les plus mainstream de la
sociologie de la police considère que le
la base c'est que la police ne met pas
en œuvre la loi et que la plupart des
policiers ne connaissent pas la loi pour
connaître être la loi, il faut avoir un
bac + 5 en droit. C'est pas la fonction
de la police. La police, elle est elle
met en place des gardien de la paix,
c'est bac + 1. C'est ça. Gardien de la
paix, c'est bac + 1.
Bah ça ça dépend même. Tu as des tu as
des ADS, des adjoints de sécurité euh
qui ont aucun diplôme dans la police.
Revenons au côte de déontologie de la
police nationale.
C'est une fiction.
Quand est-ce qu'il a changé ?
Mais il il y a en fait sous
changé récemment
le il a été mis en place en 89 ou 90
par qui ? Jox. par Jox à la suite euh
des manifes contre la loi de Vaquet et
de et du meurtre de Malekosekin où du
coup il s'agissait de dire on va
restructurer la police, on va la
moderniser et on va vous faire une
police bien propre et cetera. Euh
le fait est que en fait avec le
développement du système sécuritaire, on
a juste vu depuis ce temps-là monter le
nombre de personnes tuées par la police
mais aussi mutilé. Alors bien entendu
dans le
Quels sont vos stats, quelles sont vos
sources ? Bah les sources, c'est on fait
de l'enquête toute l'année, on récupère
le nombre de le le nom et la et le
statut social des personnes qui sont
tuées par la police. Et donc on tourne
entre, ça dépend des enfin le la
moyenne, elle est entre 12 et 16 17.
Donc on tourne autour de 15 morts euh de
personnes tuées par la police.
99 % des habitants des classes
populaires, pareil à 95 % des personnes
non blanches, des noirs et des arabes.
Vous faites des statistiques ethniques ?
Bah ethnique en fait euh social même
hein parce que c'est cette société qui
c'est autorisé en France des
statistiques ethniques ?
Non, c'est pas autorisé. C'est pas
autorisé pour l'État. Par contre, la
sociologie, elle fait ce qu'elle veut et
h et dans les pratiques réelles de la
police, c'est quelque chose qui est au
cœur euh de des usages. C'est-à-dire
même euh enfin, je sais pas si tu as
déjà fait une garde à vue ou si tu avais
déjà fait un tour dans un dans une dans
une voiture de police. Mais en fait, la
manière dont il désigne un suspect, euh
c'est directement c'est par la couleur
de peau, hein. Euh ou ce qui des fois,
ils disent na pour nord-africain,
c'est-à-dire vraiment le enfin le le
dispositif
colonial hein, de de désignation
coloniale. Revenons à notre code
déontologie. Euh, il a changé, si mes
souvenirs sont bons. Euh, d'ailleurs, on
demande à la communauté de Facty en
direct avec Capitaine Fact.
Non,
je sur à quel niveau ?
Au niveau euh de ce que doit protéger la
police ?
Bah, moi je suis pas beaucoup courant.
Mais là, les changements qu'il y a eu,
il y a eu des consignes en interne par
exemple sur les usages des armes
intermédiaires. Donc là, on a sur le le
les lanceurs de balles de défense où
donc on va ils vont pu être utilisés en
maintien de l'ordre. Mais seulement en
retour à l'ordre, on rentre dans des
trucs précis. Euh c'estàd tu as des des
usages différenciés en fonction aussi
des préfectures, en fonction des
préfets. Tu as des usages là on revient
encore une fois sur ça. L'usage réel et
les cadres théoriques, c'est pas les
mêmes. C'estàd que là, par exemple, euh
les grenades offensives qui ont été euh
théoriquement interdites après la mort
de Remé FR, et ben on en a retrouvé dans
différentes manifestations dans les mois
qu'on suivi.
l'usage par exemple des grenades de
désencerclement, ça c'est théoriquement
légalement, ça a toujours été dit, c'est
un truc qui doit être balancé dans les
pieds à je sais plus combien de mètres.
En fait, dans la plupart des cas où
elles sont utilisées, on a des on a des
retours d'expérience où bah en fait
c'est tiré en plein visage où qu'on vise
au-dessus des têtes pour que ça retombe
à ce niveau-là, que ça retombe au niveau
au niveau de du torse et cetera. En
c'est-à-dire euh
en quand je reviens sur le fait que
c'est une fiction, mais en fait ça
s'applique à tous les niveaux de la
société. Il y a des discours d'état qui
sont là pour permettre à des
institutions de fonctionner et il y a
les usages réels. Et les usages réels de
la police, c'est tout sauf de protéger
la population. Et après ça dépend de
quelle population on parle, mais oui, en
l'occurrence c'est de protéger les
classes dominantes.
Oui. Mais il y a quand même des si on
peut employer un mot trivial, il y a
quand même des cufs qui font quand même
bien leur job, qui protègent, qui
essayent de s'insérer, qui essayent de
de s'insérer dans leur biotop, qui
essayent de de redresser bah par exemple
des gamins en allant jouant au foot ou
des choses comme ça, en essayant de
faire du mentoring.
Il y a quand même des bons flics.
Moi je pense qu'ils font bien leur job
parce que leur job c'est ça.
Est-ce que vous les mettez tous dans le
même panier ? C'est pas une histoire de
bon flic, méchant flic parce que même ça
c'est une technique, c'est une technique
de psychologie sociale euh de pour gérer
des gens qu'on leur apprend. Nous, on
parle de l'institution policière et
effectivement la fonction de la police,
c'est notamment de maintenir le
socioartide, mais il y a aussi des
fonctions de reproduction du patriarcat,
du capitalisme et cetera. Et donc de ce
point de vue-là, le bon flic celui qui
fait ça. Et donc c'est la une immense
majorité, c'est tous des bons flics
parce qu'ils font ça, leur pratique. Et
c'est pas juste celui qui va t'étrangler
à la sortie du lycée, hein. Parce que
celui qui est dans son bureau et qui a
les mains très propres pendant que ça se
passe, euh moi pendant qu'on m'a mis la
tête dans les murs au commissariat de de
Toulouse, ils vont pas tous mis la tête
dans les murs. Par contre, tous les
autres, ils étaient dans leur bureau,
ils bougeaient pas, ça se passait très
bien, ils avaient pas les mains sales.
Mais l'institution, elle faisait
fonctionner ce truc-là. Et du coup c'est
et et cette institution là et ces
pratiques là, elles sont validées après
par la justice qui du coup t'empêche toi
de porterf si tu porte plainte ça mène à
rien. On voit toutes les histoires de
crimes policier. Il y a jamais un flic
qui est qui va en tôle. Et là c'est
encore pas des flics qui vont en tôle
après un
Non c'est quasi c'est ridicule. C'est de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 % sur toutes les
plaintes
dans les les conseils de discipline ils
sont jamais radiés. Et ben alors, tu vas
voir que ça valide ce que je dis, c'est
qu'en fait, on a l'immense majorité des
policiers qui ont été accusés euh de
crimes ou euh entre guillemets de bavure
parce que notre analyse aussi c'est de
dire que c'est pas des bavures mais
c'est mais que c'est un système. En
fait, la quasi totalité, ils obtiennent
les mutations qu'ils ont demandé,
c'est-à-dire en fait une récompense. Tu
vois les mecs qui voulaient partir dans
le sud depuis 15 ans, là médiatiquement
ça a chié sur le quartier. Euh
bon bref, on veut les déplacer parce que
ça a créé des révoltes dans le quartier
et ben on leur file leur mutation. Donc
déjà, ils ont une sorte de récompense et
en même quand on regarde les parcours de
ces policiers là, puisqueen fait, ils
sont jamais sortis de la police he pour
l'immense majorité, ils sont pas sortis
de la police, ils montent en grade parce
que pourquoi en on reconnaît à la à la
suite d'une affaire que ah ils ont été
très forts, ils ont réussi, ils ont subi
le la vindicte médiatique, la vindicte
populaire, ils ont ils ont ils ont tenu
bon face à tout ça. Donc on les
récompense et puis aussi
où on les protège ? Bah où on les
protège ? Oui. Enfin si les c'est
exactement ça. L'État protège les flics
qui sont accusés de de
on protège eux leur famille contre des
représailles des mesures de rétorsion.
Les faire monter en grade euh c'est pas
de l'ordre de la protection.
Parler de la mutation.
Ouais. Bah oui mais sauf qu'on dans la
pratique
fait l'avocat du diable.
Oui oui je vois bien. Mais je Tu fais
bien tu fais bien. Mais bah par exemple
une partie moi de mon travail sur
Twitter c'est que je fais de la veille.
Je fais de la veille sur les sur les
industries de sécurité, la l'armée, les
forces spéciales, la gendarmerie, la
police. Et ce qu'on voit c'est qu' ça
rigole de ça. Les flics, ils rigolent de
ça entre eux. Ah, tu veux ta mutation
que tu as pas eu depuis 12 ans ? Et ben
vas-y, règle règle un jeune. Et souvent
ils disent pas un jeune, ils disent des
mots bien plus dégueulasse que j'ai pas
du tout envie d'employer. Ils en
rigolent parce qu'en fait c'est ça le
système et que c'est pas des bavures, ça
fait partie de notre analyse. C'est pas
des erreurs, c'est pas des accidents
dans le fonctionnement d'un système où
la bonne police ce serait une police qui
protégerait les pauvres gens. Euh c'est
la fonction systémique de la police
historiquement hein. Tu regardes à
toutes les époques, la police, elle est
là pour encadrer les classes les plus
pauvres. Mais pourquoi ? Il y a il y a
une rationalité là-dedans. Parce que les
classes les plus pauvres, c'est
effectivement les classes qui menacent
l'État, qui menacent la bourgeoisie, qui
menacent les classes dominantes en
général. Et donc bien entendu, des
classes dominantes un état, ils ont
raison de se méfier des misérables parce
que les misérables, ils se souent en
général, ils se soumettent pas gentiment
à leur à la reproduction de leur de leur
galère. La gendarmerie, vous avez un
avis dessus ? Bah
après c'est pas des j'ai des avis mais
ces avis ils découlent aussi de
d'enquête. on est en train de si vous
m'avez invité, c'est parce que je fais
un travail de recherche et puis je le
fais pas tout seul hein. Ben la
gendarmerie c'est une force
militaroicière, c'estàd c'est une force
militaire au départ qui est de plus en
plus employée. Donc elle a été employée
bien entendu dans les campagnes, mais à
différentes époques, on lui a demandé de
faire du maintien de l'ordre et donc
maintenant donc et en France mais dans
la plupart des des puissances
occidentales, on a des formes de de
forces gendarmiques ou militaire ou
policières qui du coup sont
particulièrement
employés pour faire circuler
les nouvelles formes de guerre sociale.
C'est par exemple la gendarmerie elle
est employée dans les guerres
néocoloniales. Elle est employée dans
tout le précarré france-africain. C'est
là-bas qu'elle fait donc en terme
militaire c'est du contrôle des foules.
C'est la gendarmerie qu'on envoie et ben
qu'on envoie en Côte d'Ivoire
réprimer les manifestations civiles face
aux face aux manipulations françaises,
face au Tchad
en RDC et cetera quand il y a quand il y
a besoin de
enfin par je pense je dis au Tchad parce
que je pense quand la France a besoin de
rétablir un dictateur, je pense à DBI
qui est menacé par les révoltes de sa
propre population et ben on envoie on
envoie des troupes qui participent à ça.
Donc bref, la gendarmerie, bah par
exemple, c'est des forces qui vont
pouvoir faire du contrôle des foules,
c'est-à-dire une un déploiement
militaire, une gestion militaire des
foules qui peut monter jusqu'à l'emploi
de l'emploi de la l'emploi l'emploi du
feu, jusqu'à la la possibilité de tirer
et qui vont être régulièrement utilisés
à l'intérieur du territoire dans les
quartiers populaires mais on les voit de
plus en plus dans les luttes sociales
où on va leur demander là de faire du
maintien de l'ordre, c'est-à-dire un des
des doctrines d'emploi où ils sont pas
censés monter jusqu'au feu. Mais en
fait, c'est les mêmes unités, c'est les
mêmes personnels avec quasiment les
mêmes matériels, pas le même cadre légal
d'emploi, mais c'est ces troupes là qui
font passer une grande partie des
dispositifs militaires
et et néocoloniaux dans le domaine
sécuritaire, qui importe des idées, qui
importent des pratiques et qui après bah
les les répandent dans le reste de la
police mais aussi dans la sécurité
privée et puis ben dans tout le domaine
idéologique des sociétés de contrôle.
Est-ce que vous avez suivi le fait qu'on
puisse utiliser Je crois que c'est le
calibre 762 euh sur le territoire ?
Est-ce que les forces de police peuvent
être dotées de ce type de calibre ?
Ce calibre là, je sais pas. Je
franchement je m'y connais pas très bien
en ça. Par contre, les les forces de
l'ordre ont été dotées de fusil
d'assaut. Euh et bah d'ailleurs, un mois
après qu'elles en étaient dotées, il y a
il y a un type dans son jardin qui s'est
fait qui s'est fait descendre par une
rafale, hein, pas par une balle, hein,
une rafale de fusil d'assaut. Où ça ?
Euh je dirais Grenoble, je crois
une rafale de fusil d'assaut qui a été
balancé contre lui ou c'est simplement
un mec qui restait sur le trigger ?
Non non le le je moi je connais pas le
le dossier exactement. La police
justifie en disant qu'il avait une arme
qui était peut-être factisme en tout cas
que et et au final il y a de toute façon
il y a rien eu. Il y a eu une plainte et
il y a rien eu.
Et pareil dans les semaines qu'on suivit
on a qui sait qui s'est baladé
ostensiblement avec les fusils d'assaut
? c'est les bacs, c'est les unités de
bac dans les quartiers populaires qui
venaient bien montrer qu'elles étaient
dotées de ces armes-là. Et puis depuis
euh depuis le mouvement sur la loi
travail aussi, on les a vu apparaître
dans les manifestations dans les
manifestations contre la loi travail et
son monde ou donc des des forces qui
sont censées.
Ils ont peut-être été dotés de ce type
d'armement pour des questions de
terrorisme. Ah ben alors pourquoi il
pourquoi alors on les laisse les
employer et les déployer ostensiblement
euh face à des luttes sociales face à
face au quartier populaire si c'est
contre le terror
parce que peut-être que dans les
quartiers populaires, c'est aussi un
foyer et un terro d'islamisation
profonde et que peut-être que ils font
les coques avec leur pétoir, ils sont
très contents de montrer leur nouveaux
joujou mais c'est peut-être une utilité
de de montrer qu'ils sont armés
lourdement. Bah en l'occurrence, j'ai
enfin vous me direz mais on n pas eu
l'impression que le la la la montée en
puissance des armements et empêcher les
attentats depuis lor. Enfin que ce soit
au Bataclan ou que ce soit, on n pas vu
on n pas vu le fait que des unités de
police de de terrain de quartier et
cetera a pu empêcher quoi que ce soit.
Euh en l'occurrence le le nombre
d'attentats, il évolue plutôt en
fonction des déploiements et des
bombardements français aux proches et au
Moyen-Orient. Euh et non, le
revendication et ça pareil, on le voit
quand on suit les sur les réseaux
sociaux euh euh les fils policiers mais
aussi au niveau des revendications des
syndicats de police. Euh eux considèrent
que ça fait partie euh de l'arsenal
légitime qu'ils doivent avoir pour se
faire respecter dans les quartiers
populaires. Et
bah personnellement, je pense que ça a
vraiment rien à voir avec de
l'antiterrorisme. L'antiterrorisme,
c'est la logique de légitimation, de
justification d'une montée en puissance
des armements. Et parce qu'en plus ces
armements, enfin le la montée en
puissance de ces armements, elle répond
aussi à des intérêts industriels. Il y a
des il y a il y a tout un tout un
système d'industrie qui profite
allègrement de
du développement de l'armement policier.
J'ai lu un entretien qui s'appelle État
d'urgence et business de la sécurité,
entretien avec Mathieu Rigost.
Euh vous parlez de la militarisation de
l'espace urbain. Est-ce que vous pouvez
développer un peu ?
Et ben, c'est lié à tout ce qu'on
raconte depuis tout à l'heure, c'est le
fait que bah notamment depuis les années
60, mais en fait il y a un il y a une
généalogie qui est plus longue, qu'on
voit une transformation des formes de la
guerre et notamment et une montée en
puissance des industries qui sont liées
à la guerre. Alors les deux grands les
deux grandes ruptures historiques, c'est
les deux guerres mondiales où du coup on
a à l'intérieur des classes dominantes,
à l'intérieur des bourgeoisies
occidentales, la fabrication de blocs
industriels qui vivent de la guerre
permanente parce que ce qui a été appelé
les complexes militaraux industriels.
Qui a développé le le
on va dire le concept de guerre
permanente. Ça commence par un L
de guerre permanente. Bah enfit moi je
sais pas si c'est un un concept qui
appartient à une personne, c'est un
plutôt un champ théorique d'analyse.
Après le
vous avez lu Close Vitz ?
J'ai vu des j'ai lu des articles sur
Close Vit. Après moi c'est pas du tout.
Excusez-moi de vous avoir coupé.
Non, il y a pas de souci. Sur la
militarisation.
Et du coup la militarisation c'est un
processus long de transformation des
sociétés occidentales principalement
mais maintenant ça touche c'est c'est
mondial et qui est lié au à la montée en
puissance des industries euh qui vivent
de la guerre permanente.
[Musique]
Donc ces industries là, elles ont
bouleversé la classe politique pendant
les deux guerres mondiales et puis dans
l'après 68 ou même plutôt plus pendant
le moment 68 où du coup on a des à la
fois des révoltes sociales partout dans
le monde, dans la jeunesse, mais aussi
un développement des des mouvements
révolutionnaires anticolonialistes.
En fait, les états du monde occidental
sont face au fait que bah émerge des
nouvelles formes de résistance, de
révolte, de contre-attaque qui
deviennent beaucoup plus difficile à
gérer. Et donc, on va rouvrir le
répertoire de l'emploi de la guerre à
l'intérieur du territoire et contre des
populations civiles.
L'ennemi intérieur.
Bah, par exemple, on va on va d'un point
de vue idéologique et imaginaire, on va
aller chercher ces figures-là parce que
ça permet de justifier euh tout ça, mais
ça va passer à plein de niveaux. Ça va
ça va passer donc on l'a dit par la
transformation des dispositifs
policiers. Donc là quand on dit
militarisation, il s'agit pas de dire
que c'est la guerre à l'intérieur. Il
s'agit qu'il y a un processus de
transformation des sociétés de contrôle,
des formes du contrôle qui va puiser
dans les répertoires de la guerre. Il
s'agit pas de dire que la police est
devenue l'armée mais qu'il y a des
hybridations entre les domaines
policiers et les domaines militaires. Et
puis ça marche dans les deux sens.
C'estàd qu'on voit que les formes de la
guerre, des guerres néocoloniales, de la
guerre à l'extérieur, bah aussi prennent
des formes policières de police globale
euh où pareil les les forces spéciales à
l'extérieur des fois vont s'intéresser
aux formes policières de contrôle dans
les quartiers populaires euh parce que
elles vont parce que ça a un intérêt
pour ell
et donc on insiste à la fois dans les
imaginaires, dans les dispositifs de
pouvoir euh et puis dans la composition
des des classes sociales à une
importation de toute une série
dispositifs qui viennent de la guerre,
qui viennent du militaire, qui viennent
du colonial et ben et qui sont utilisés
pour réagencer. Il s'agit pas de dire
que on est dans un dans le l'importation
directe et le calque de deux situations,
mais qu'il y a réagencement, il y a
hybridation, il y a restructuration
depuis ces répertoires là. Et du coup,
ça on le voit dans l'ensemble des
sociétés impérialistes occidentales,
mais en fait ça touche le monde entier.
On a donc des des sociétés qui
qui suivent ce fil de restructuration.
ces lignes là.
Vous avez voté quoi aux dernières
élections ?
Je vote pas moi.
Pourquoi ? parce que je suis pour la
démocratie directe. Je je considère que
c'est au peuple de s'auto-organiser par
eux-mêmes et que ce que eux ce que là le
système appelle démocratie, c'est plutôt
la dictature des riches, c'est la
dictature des classes dominantes et que
j'ai pas envie d'aller donner ma caution
pour aller pour justifier X ou Y qui de
toute façon va continuer à nous
exploiter, à nous opprimer, à faire du
business nucléaire, militaire et cetera,
toutes sortes de choses auxquelles on
peut pas toucher, va continuer à
reproduire la France-Afrique, la
répression dans les quartiers populaires
le patriarcat et cetera. Non, moi je
crois aux forme d'autoorganisation, aux
forme d'autonomie des opprimés, des
dominés et que ça ça se fait au
quotidien localement. C'est des luttes
qui sont permanentes, qui sont longues,
qui sont dures, mais que c'est pas en
c'est pas en déléguant notre pouvoir à
des gens qu'on rien à faire de nos vies,
que ça va changer quoi que ce soit parce
que c'est plutôt l'inverse. Je crois, on
est dans des sociétés pyramidales où la
minorité qui est en haut, elle est
assise sur notre dos. Alors si
j'ai pas envie de participer de à leur
donner les moyens de de continuer à
faire ça.
C'est un darwinisme économique
le capitalisme
d'une certaine manière. On pourrait dire
ça en tout cas c'est le c'est le
l'organisation de la domination d'une de
toutes les dominations en fait. Enfin,
le le capitalisme, c'est une domination
économique, mais les systèmes de
domination, ils fonctionnent entre eux
et ils favorisent toujours les plus
forts. Le patriarcat favorise la classe
des hommes, euh administre ses
privilèges, euh ses intérêts.
le la suprématie blanche
administre et organise la domination,
les privilèges, les intérêts
des classes
des classes qui bénéficient qui qui qui
profitent du racisme, le capitalisme,
c'est ça au niveau économique et et puis
il y a encore d'autres systèmes de
domination qui s'articulent.
Tout ça fonctionne ensemble.
On va revenir à notre premier sujet.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me résumer selon
votre point de vue l'histoire de la BAC
? Ouais. Alors, pareil, c'est pas un
c'est pas un point de vue qui vient
comme ça, hein. C'est le c'est le fruit
de de recherche, d'enquête. Euh donc la
la BAC, le la brigade anticriminalité,
elle a plusieurs histoires qui se
mêlent. Il y a deux généalogies
principales. Il y a une généalogie
qu'on peut dire coloniale et il y a une
généalogie qu'on peut dire néolibérale.
Donc la généalogie coloniale, elle puise
dans des dispositifs d'abord dans
l'entre de guerre puis dans le juste
après la deuxième guerre mondiale qui
sont les brigades nord-africaines qui
étaient des brigades de police qui
étaient chargé du contrôle des Arabes à
Paris très clairement et qui utilisait
toutes sortes de dispositifs de
surveillance, de contrainte, de
coerstition qu'on retrouve he dans les
bacs d'aujourd'hui que ce soit la
pratique de chasse à l'homme,
d'étranglement,
de persécution, d'humiliation
brimade et cetera, insulte à caractère
raciste et sexuel et cetera. Des preuves
de ça ? Ah
bah bien sûr, il y a des il y a des
travaux en en sociologie, en histoire,
il y a travaux d'Emmanuel Blanchard. Euh
bon, enfin, il y a il y a toute une
série d'études sur le sur les brigades
nord-africaines. Et donc juste après la
deuxième guerre mondiale, euh bon, il y
a une volonté de de construire le mythe
de la France résistante et cetera et de
et de le mythe golien de on passe à
autre chose complètement et donc ça y
est, c'est fini, c'est fini le racisme
et cetera. Et donc on dissous ces
ces brigades là, enfin le on on enlève
le terme en fait parce que la la
fonction va être produite puisque les
classes dominantes ont toujours besoin
d'encadrer le prolétariat issu de la
colonisation.
Et donc on va avoir des brigades qui
vont s'appeler les brigades agression et
violence mais c'est à leur tête on va
mettre les anciens des brigades
nord-africaines et puis qui vont
réintroduire les mêmes types de
dispositifs de pratique.
Pas contre il y a pas contre dans cet
anagramme là. Il y a pas brigad contre
la violence et les agressions.
Non, c'est les brigades agression et et
violence. D'ailleurs, il
c'est pas brigad contre les agressions
et violence.
Il y a pas le contre, mais c'est ce que
ça sous-entend. bien sûr euh le pouvoir
utilise pas de termes qui le qui le
gênent. Mais
bon, on va retrouver le même type de
pratique dans les BAV
où pareil vont de une nouvelle
génération et qui là vont être beaucoup
plus en contact avec les avec les
guerres d'indépendance
vont même se radicaliser hein du point
de vue de du point de vue de du point de
vue raciste. Et
et donc les générations qui passent dans
ces dans ces unités là, ça va être les
premiers chefs des unités qu'on va
appeler les brigades de surveillance de
nuit au tout début des années 70 et qui
sont les ancêtres des bacs. C'est donc
les premiers chefs de ces unitésl sont
des anciens de ces brigades. Moi je dis
endocoloniales. Alors c'est un concept
ça fait un peu universitaire. C'est pour
parler de colonies intérieures sans dire
que c'est exactement des colonies, mais
justement pour parler de ces unités qui
réagencent des dispositifs coloniaux à
l'intérieur.
Donc ça c'est une des généalogies. Le
prototype des bacs euh dérive euh d'une
généalogie coloniale qui sont les
brigades euh de surveillance des
nord-africains, les brigades
nord-africaines et les BAV. Et de
l'autre côté, on a une généalogie qui
est qu'on peut dire plutôt néolibérale
et qui elle naît dans la près 68 autour
de toute la naissance de des sociétés de
contrôle et euh et qui consiste à dire
qu'il faut absolument rationaliser,
optimiser euh le le fonctionnement de la
police. ce qui va donner plus tard le le
les ce qu'on appelle les politiques du
chiffre mais en fait qui sont qui sont
des qui sont des politiques
structurelles dans dans la police
contemporaine et qui consiste à
fabriquer et déployer des formes
policières qui vont être le plus
rentable possible. Et donc dans ces
formes policières, on va aller chercher
dans les répertoires qu'on considère
être les plus
les plus rentables et donc notamment
dans ces dans ces répertoires coloniaux.
Et donc on va créer des petites unités
de quelques agents survirilisés
qui adorent aller chasser dans les
quartiers populaires. Donc il y en a
beaucoup bah c'est certains qui
reviennent de la guerre d'Algérie ou et
qui ont envie de continuer ça qui ont
envie de continuer ça en métropole.
toutes sortes de toutes sortes de gens
que ça fait
que ça qui trouvent du des convictions
et du plaisir dans le fait d'aller
d'aller faire la police dans les
quartiers populaires. Et donc on va leur
demander de devenir rentable notamment
par l'emploi de du flagrant délit. Et le
flagrant délit en fait ça suppose pour
une force policière donc d'attraper
quelqu'un en train de faire quelque
chose. Ça c'est rentable dans l'idée
enfin dans dans la logique dans dans la
logique gouvernementale parce que ça
serait directement utilisable par un
juge pour en faire une affaire. Et donc
ça ça fait un point, ça fait des bâtons,
ça permet de compter, ça permet une une
mathématique euh médiatique aussi de
dire "On a on a arrêté tant de gens, on
a résolu tant d'affaires, donc regardez
le gouvernement, le nouveau ministère de
l'intérieur est bien meilleur que celui
d'avant et cetera."
Et ça repose aussi sur un fonctionnement
dans la pratique qui change beaucoup de
choses. C'est que quand on demande à des
policiers de faire du flagrant d'élit et
ben pour pouvoir arrêter quelqu'un
exactement où il au moment où il est en
train de faire quelque chose et ben on
va voir se mettre en place des formes
policières qui accompagnent
la commission d'un délit, d'un crime,
voir qu'ils vont pouvoir la susciter.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par qu'ils
vont pouvoir la susciter ?
Bah par exemple qu'on va c'est des
choses qu'on voit régulièrement dans
différents quartiers. bah des unités de
bac qui laissent exister un point de
fixation, un point de deal avec lequel
on va surveiller des gars. On infiltre,
c'est l'utilisation énormément de
l'infiltration. Donc ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on retrouve dans la police dans
toute l'histoire de la police. La police
utilise des délinquants, des je mets des
guillemets he des criminels. Je mets des
guillemets parce que c'est la c'est
l'État, c'est la loi qui dit qu'est-ce
qui est délinquant, qu'est-ce qui est
criminel. Des balances mais aussi des
types qui travaillent vraiment dedans.
C'està-dire et avec qui on va pouvoir
voir tout un le fonctionnement de tout
un un circuit paralégal. C'est-à-dire
que tu as des du coup tu as des tu as
des gens dans la police et dans la
justice qui vont vivre aussi de ces
trafics là, qui vont récupérer un peu de
matière, de l'argent, euh faire carrière
sur ça parce que du coup le être un tu
vas pouvoir te présenter comme un super
policier qui a fait plein d'affaires
justement parce que tu as infiltré plein
de gars dans un dans un sur un marché
par exemple, sur un marché sur un
business de deal. Euh bon, du coup, je
reviens à la généalogie des bacs, mais
cette logique de rentabilisation,
d'optimisation, de rationalisation euh
de le de la productivité policière
et ben elle va aller vers le
développement de petits groupes de des
unités commando de la police. Et là, on
retouche à la à la militarisation,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va aussi chercher à
adapter pour l'intérieur du territoire
ces formes qui se développent de plus en
plus dans les guerres néocoloniales qui
est la forme commando du petit groupe
d'unité spécial euh qui peut naviguer à
l'intérieur, autour et à l'extérieur du
droit euh pour réaliser son coût, son
affaire. Euh et donc on va bah on va
voir ces deux logiques-là, la logique
néocoloniale et la la logique
néolibérale fusionner tout au long des
années 70, prendre réellement forme dans
les années 80 et être généralisé euh à
la fin des années 80, au début des
années 90 sous Passois notamment parce
que on a bien parce que du coup à ce
moment-là le dispositif a bien été
testé, on a vu ce que ça produisait. On
a vu que par exemple allié de la BAC et
des médias autour d'un quartier
populaire, ça produisait des révoltes
forcément quand tu enfin que ça ça
produisait des révoltes qu'on peut
médiatiser et donc que ça ouvrait des
nouveaux circuits d'intérêt,
c'est-à-dire que on pouvait la BAC
produit des révoltes parce que avec le
harcèlement, l'oppression, les
brutalisations, les gens se laissent pas
faire, se révoltent. Et quand on a les
médias autour et ben on est capable de
construire l'image d'un quartier dont on
peut plus rien faire, un quartier perdu,
euh une zone sensible dont il y a plus
rien à récupérer et cetera.
Vous avez déjà fait un tour à Grini ?
À Grini ? Non. Mais par contre, je suis
né je suis né à Jeun Viller, j'y a passé
30 ans, qui est du coup un des lieux
d'expérimentation des des nouvelles
politiques de rénovation urbaine parce
que c'est là que je voulais en venir,
c'est que quand tu allies des polices
féroces
et des médias, tu peux construire
l'image d'un quartier dont on peut plus
rien faire et donc tu peux mettre en
place tout un programme de rénovation
urbaine et qui consiste en fait à
détruire de l'habitat populaire qui est
souvent euh qui pourrait être réadapté
ou en tout cas si On demandait son avis
à la population. En général, la
population, elle est pas pour les
destructions et en général, elle met en
place des luttes, des résistances face à
ces destructions-là. Bien entendu, sont
jamais écouté. Euh et donc l'alliance
euh des grands médias, des médias
dominants et de de d'unité féroces de
police permet euh de mettre en place
tout des programmes de rénovation
urbaine qui sont devenus vraiment le le
cœur de la restruction de la
restructuration du capitalisme
contemporain et où on voit que les
investissements géants qui sont faits en
ce moment dans Toulouse Métropole, Grand
Paris et cetera qui est-ce qui profite
en premier lieu de ça ? C'est les mêmes
industriels qui profitent des guerres
néocoloniales. C'est les grands
industriels du bâtiment Vinc, BUIG et
cetera. Les grands industriels de la
sécurité, du numérique, Talè et C.
Il y a la farche qui s'est fait attraper
là.
Bah la farche s'est fait attraper mais
comme en général la plupart des affaires
c'est le je sais pas s'ils sont encore
coupables.
Non. Bon en en tout cas ceux dont ils
sont accusés a priori de les
présemption d'innocence.
Oui. Oui. Euh c'est important. Moi ce
que je ce que je voulais défendre par
rapport à l'analyse c'est qu'en général
les affaires qui émergent et dont on
entend parler médiatiquement et enfin
qui sont déroulées médiatiquement c'est
le sommet de l'iceberg.
Revenons à la militarisation de l'espace
urbain. Quand la ville change, les
policiers ou la préfecture de police
s'est conviée aux réunions de
d'urbanisme. Pourquoi ?
Bah parce qu'on considère que que la
sécurité c'est un des c'est un des
enjeux fondamentaux de la nouvelle
ville. Mais d'ailleurs
comme les services incendie, les
pompiers et choses comme ça. Non,
je dirais pas comme
pourquoi pas comme ?
Bah parce que je pense qu'on donne
beaucoup plus de pouvoir et de
légitimité au service de sécurité qu'au
qu'au pompiers ou qu'à la bon ou à la
sécurité même dans les services de
sécurité à la sécurité répressive que à
la sécurité civ. Quand les pompiers
quand les pompiers sont obligés de se
former euh l'exécution de leur leur
métier en période insurrectionnelle, ils
sont obligés de de se faire assister par
la police pour aller éteindre des feux
des fois volontaires où il y a des
guetapons à cuf. Euh qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de ça ?
Moi j'en pense rien mais on c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qu'on a on a on
a on a du mal à à comprendre quand on
l'a pas vécu, quand on l'a pas observé
depuis les quartiers populaires. Ouais.
Mais dans les quartiers populaires, en
fait, on le voit très bien. Euh en
général, c'est comme pour la police en
vérité, quand les gens ont ont besoin
d'une intervention, ça vient pas parce
que justement euh il y a tout ce mythe
que on va se faire attaquer et cetera.
Et à l'inverse,
ils se prennent des pavasses quand même
les pompiers.
Ça dépend, ça dépend, ça dépend. C'est
pas tout le temps ça. C'est ça c'est
souvent ce qui est c'est souvent ce qui
est mis en avant.
Mais de l'autre côté en faitch quand on
appelle quand on appelle les pompiers
pour un incendie et ben il y a la police
qui arrive et la police elle arrive dans
un quartier populaire, il se passe tout
le temps la même chose. Harcèlement,
humiliation, répression, ça vient casser
des familles, ça vient casser des vies,
ça vient casser des corps, ça vient
casser des histoires. Et donc bah oui
dans la jeunesse souvent c'est quand
même enfin je je même pas le le
délégitimer en disant que c'est les plus
jeunes, mais en tout cas c'est parmi euh
les jeunes qui euh
sont dans la rue le plus jeune enfin
c'est pour dire les plus pauvres aussi
hein. C'est-à-dire ceux qu'on ceux qui
peuvent pas rester dans les appartements
parce que il y a pas la place parce que
ou parce que c'est un salubre et cetera
qui se retrouvent dans la rue le plus
tôt possible qui se retrouve face au
fait que quand les pompiers viennent ils
viennent avec la police et que tout le
monde se fait réprimer cadrer. Et du
coup, bah oui, il y a une assimilation
euh parmi une partie des habitants entre
euh force de pompiers et force de police
parce que les pompiers ne viennent plus
sans la police et donc à chaque fois que
les pompiers viennent et ben tout le
monde se fait brutaliser euh et cetera.
Et quand quand UPS refuse de passer dans
certains quartiers, euh pourquoi à votre
avis ? Parce que ça peut arriver qu'il
se fasse qu'il se fasse braquer.
Dépouiller.
Oui. Oui. Mais alors et pourquoi on
braque et on dépouille des camions du PS
dans certains quartiers, pas trop dans
les habitants de la jeunesse du 16e,
elle fait pas ça
parce qu'elle a pas besoin. Euh si elle
a la jeunesse du 16e, si elle veut la
dernière console à la mode, si elle veut
si elle a besoin d'un billet, elle
demande à papa et maman.
Revenons à la BAC. Vous parliez de MAD
dans cette petite entretien. C'est quoi
un MAD ?
Une MAD, une mise à disposition. Bah
c'était ça fait partie de ce qui
permet de comprendre les politiques du
chiffre.
Donc une mise à disposition, c'est un
point dans la carrière et d'un
commissaire, d'un enfin dans un pour un
commissariat et puis bah aussi pour pour
des pour des policiers. C'est le fait de
eux disent faire une affaire, les les
bac, ils disent faire des crânes
souvent. et ben c'est le fait quand tu
attrapes quelqu'un et que tu peux
transformer son cas en affaire
judiciaire qui va être donc le le
procureur va ouvrir une procédure et que
cette procédure va être
va avoir une va avoir une conclusion
judiciaire.
Ça fait un point. Ça appelle ça une MAD,
une mise à disposition. Et donc un par
un commissaire qui a envie de faire
carrière, qui a envie de grimper, qui a
envie d'être connu, qui a envie de qui a
envie de qui a envie de grimper, il a il
a tout intérêt à développer des unités
qui fabriquent beaucoup de MAD
ou FRMAC.
Je oui, je sais pas, je travaille pas
sur ça. Euh et pour développer des
unités qui font des MAD, bah par
exemple, les bacs font beaucoup de MAD
parce que une MAD, donc une une mise à
disposition, on en euh on en fait une en
attrapant une personne sans papier par
exemple. Donc ça dans la pratique
réelle, ça veut dire contrôler des noirs
et des arabes dans la rue hein avec
enfin et qu'on a d'un point de vue
vestimentaire qui appartient aux classes
populaires parce qu' en général ça ça se
produit moins sur les classes dominantes
même si euh donc les c'est les
infractions à à la législation euh sur
le droit des étrangers les ILE ou
ou des ILS des infractions à la
législation sur les stupéfiants pour
attraper des stupéfiants
Euh, on arrête des jeunes autour d'une
université, d'un quartier populaire et
cetera. Ça marche, ça marche assez bien.
Euh ben ça, ça chaque arrestation de ce
type là, ça fait une MAD. Mais arrêter
un délinquant financier, ça ferait une
MAD aussi. un truc pour lequel il faut
plusieurs mois, plusieurs années euh
d'enquête et pour lequel on va se
confronter à à des à des antagonismes
face à face à des magistrats, euh des
politiciens, toutes sortes toutes sortes
de gens qui qui participent à
l'existence de ces business dans les
classes dominantes.
Parler de l'affaire Kusac là ou quoi ?
Oh,
on peut on pourra faire des listes qu'en
finirait plus. Alors si finirait plus au
moins trois exemples
de de délinquence financière
mais des des des scandales d'état. Il il
y en a en permanence. Ça va de l'affaire
ELF, les les frégates de Taïwan euh le
nucléaire enfin c'est
tous les t tous les marchés enfin là je
pense à Rev la la la présence Banane le
déploiement de Barkan il est lié à des
intérêts industriel
c'est ça ?
C'est pas Uramine
quoi.
Euh Ra, il y avait pas un scandale avec
Uramine aussi ?
Non mais le le scandale il est de fond.
Il est que le le il y a un déploiement
militaire d'occupation du Sahel qui est
là pour protéger les intérêts euh d'une
d'une firme géante du nucléaire auquel
on n jamais demandé à qui que ce soit en
France si on était d'accord ni et ni
pour ni pour l'arme nucléaire, ni pour
l'électricité nucléaire, ni pour qu'on
aille piller une partie de l'Afrique
pour extraire de l'uranium.
On leur apporte la civilisation. On vous
a pas dit ça 15 fois.
Ouais. Bah ça ça c'était le c'était le
régime de justification de de la
conquête coloniale
dans les années
des années 50 aux années 80 90, on
utilisait plutôt le le régime de
justification humanitaire. Donc pareil,
on allait donc là on allait pas
transmettre la civilisation mais on
allait sauver c'est Kouchner et les et
les sacs de riz et cetera.
Kouchner il a quand même un peu aidé non
? Kouchner, il est un c'est un des
rouages, enfin comme d'autres hein, je
veux dire, c'est c'est un dérouage de du
néocolonialisme et de et de la
justification justement humanitaire de
des nouvelles formes de déploiement de
militaire euh de la France-Afrique, mais
aussi des des reformulations économiques
de de ce système de pillage.
Et donc on est passé du discours de la
civilisation à l'humanitaire et depuis
fin des années 90, début des années
2000, le régime de justification c'est
l'antiterrorisme. On prétend que on va
protéger
pour le coup le les populations du Sahel
du terrorisme. Alors que bien entendu le
les attentats au Pakistan,
je le l'armée et les l'industrie
française, çaintéresse pas du tout
d'aller protéger les Pakistanais contre
le contre le
C'est con parce que les Pakistanais, ils
sont cool. Bon, je vais vous demander
qu'on fasse une expérience de pensée,
vous et moi. Euh, j'aimerais que vous
défendiez la police pendant pendant les
5 minutes.
Non, mais moi je fais de la recherche en
sciences sociales, je peux pas te faire
des trucs comme ça. C'est même pas d'un
point de vue idéologique. C'est ça veut
dire quoi la défendre ? Mettez-vous à la
place de d'un baque ?
Mais non, je peux pas faire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Mais parce que c'est pas ma je peux pas
réfléchir à la place d'un c'est même une
des bases de l'analyse matérialiste,
c'est qu'en fait on nos idées sont
produites par nos conditions de vie, par
notre existence socio-historique, par la
place qu'on occupe dans la société. Et
donc bien entendu me et et ma réflexion,
elle est basée sur un travail mais elle
est aussi basée sur mon parcours de vie.
Est-ce que vous
pardon ?
Je disais tout à l'heure j'ai grandi à
Jeunviller, je participe au lutte social
et bien entendu et ça faut jamais faut
jamais le cacher, mon analyse critique,
elle est le fruit de la rencontre entre
ce travail d'enquête mais aussi ma
position. Je suis je suis précaire dans
la vie de tous les jours. Je subis la
police dans les dans les mouvements
sociaux, dans les quartiers où j'habite.
Mes frères et sœurs se font se font se
font opprimés et cetera. Je peux pas me
mettre à la place de de quelqu'un que je
suis pas. Par contre, je peux dire
effectivement si si on avait envie
d'entendre ça que oui, la police est un
appareil au service des classes
dominantes et qu'on on peut même
considérer euh après il il pourrait
aller trouver d'autres boulots hein, des
des boulots de merde, il y en a d'autres
hein euh qui et qui
c'est pas un boulot de merde policier
quand même.
Bon, chacun on pense ce qu'il veut mais
en tout cas on peut aller trouver
d'autres boulots. Ça c'est pour ça c'est
pour dire que ils sont pas victimes de
leur de leur choix.
Est-ce que vous avez étudié ? Et en
l'occurrence effectivement la police est
au service de la reproduction d'un
système pyramidal et des classes
dominantes et que en gros ils sont
utilisés comme des chiens de garde.
Et voilà. Et du coup on les
Est-ce que vous avez étudié la
souffrance au sein même de la police ?
Par exemple, le taux de suicide pas
étudier moi, on la connaît.
Les taux de suicide, vous les connaissez
?
Oui. Oui. C'est une cinquantaine par an.
C'est en augmentation, en baisse.
C'est en augmentation. Ouais, c'est en
augmentation légère. Mais par exemple
justement c'est un c'est
les dépressions, les arrêts de travail,
des choses comme ça.
Mais et dans le bâtiment hein, et dans
les usines,
on viendra avec le bâtiment. Mais je
veux dire, a il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de professions où les gens ont
des emplois beaucoup plus durs, où il y
a des taux de suicide, des des taux de
mortalité bien plus élevés et où les
gens font pas partie d'un d'un appareil
d'écrasement des classes populaires.
Parce que c'est bien ça la différence,
c'est que la police, ça fait pas partie
de la classe ouvrière, ça produit ça
produit pas des richesses matérielles
qui vont bénéficier à d'autres ou quoi
que ce soit. C'est un appareil
d'encadrement et de contrôle. Alors si
tu veux, ça produit du contrôle. Ça
produit aussi peut-être du calme et le
calme produit aussi du business.
Mais quel calme ? Pas dans les quartiers
populaires, ça produit du calme dans le
16e. Oui. Dans les dans les dans les
quartiers privilégiés, ça produit du
calme pour les classes dominantes mais
ça produit pas du calme pour les classes
dominées. Ça c'est ça c'est sûr. Et mais
là du coup, c'est peut-être bien de le
dire par rapport à ces taux de suicide,
c'est que en fait les syndicats de
police mettent souvent en avant l'idée
que les les policiers se feraient tuer
dans les quartiers populaires et cetera.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il soit
armé et que quand les jeunes quand des
jeunes se font tuer par la police,
finalement ce serait que le fruit
de d'un cycle de violence. Les policiers
euh
tuer en service par des civils, c'est
ridicule. C'estàd il il y a il y a
chaque vie est importante quand même.
Chaque vie est importante.
Oui. Non non mais c'est pas je dis
ridicule en terme quantitatif. Les
policiers ne meurent pas tués par des
civils en service ni dans les quartiers
populaires ni ailleurs. Les policiers
ils meurent principalement.
de suicide parce que justement ils ont
comme je te dis un travail de merde
avec leur arme de service
et une et une vie de merde avec le leur
arme de service que d'ailleurs
maintenant ils ont le droit d'avoir en
dehors du service. D'ailleurs les femmes
de policiers hein le le taux de
de crimes conjugaux dans la police, il
est je crois trois fois plus élevé que
dans le reste de la population. C'estàd
que les femmes de policiers subissent la
la violence masculine et policière de
plein fouet
ou je vais je vais me permettre de
reformuler ça si vous m'autorisez. Les
femmes de policiers subissent aussi les
névroses que cette ce métier impose à
leur mari.
Oui. Oui. Aussi. Bien. Oui, aussi.
Aussi. Et h pour revenir sur le les
policiers ne meurent pas en étant tués
par des civils, ni dans les quartiers
populaires ni ailleurs. Ils meurent
principalement donc euh de suicide parce
que euh leurs conditions, leur métier,
leur vie euh les amène à ça. Et là donc
on peut le dire en on peut le dire,
c'est eux aussi c'est la police, c'est
l'institution policière qui les amène à
cette vie qui les amène à se à se
suicider. OK,
il meurt d'accident de voiture parce
qu'il roule comme des dingues, il faut
le dire. Enfin, nous par on le vit on le
vit régulièrement. Les seules enfin les
seuls régulièrement quand tu manques de
te faire renverser par une voiture qui
qui roule super vite et qui respecte pas
les feux et cetera, ça arrive très
souvent que ce soit des policiers. Bref,
les policiers, ils meurent de suicide,
d'accident de voiture et à
l'entraînement. C'est ça les principaux.
Et quand ils sont abattus par quelqu'un,
c'est la plupart du temps encore une
fois au fusil ou en zone enfin
principalement en zone rurale.
C'est-à-dire ce mythe qui ferait que euh
les jeunes des quartiers populaires se
font descendre ou étranglés et cetera
par des policiers parce que finalement
la jeunesse des classes populaires euh
mettrait en péril la vie des policiers.
C'est surréaliste. Ça n'a ça repose sur
rien de réel
du tout.
Ah bah oui, du tout. Il y a pas de
mutilation.
Il
Oui, il y a des contre-attaques. Oui, il
y a des contre-attaques et ça je pense
qu'il faut même le prendre au il faut il
faut le regarder objectivement comme
quelque chose de enfin c'està dire on on
n'est pas avec la colère contre la
police. Il y a pas de d'enfants qui
naissent en colère contre la police.
C'est quelque chose qui se construit
quand depuis moi je me rappelle enfin ça
ça commence à apparaître en primaire en
fait quand tu vois.
Est-ce que vous pensez Est-ce que vous
pensez favoriser la colère contre la
police ?
Moi je favorise rien du tout. J'essaie
de fabriquer des outils mais par contre
oui, je suis en colère ça, je vais pas
vous le je vais pas vous le cacher et je
fais partie de beaucoup de gens qui sont
en colère contre la police et mais c'est
pas c'est pas moi qui par million scand
tout le monde déteste la police dans le
mouvement contre la loi travail. Euh
c'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé et c'est
pas des ni des chercheurs. Euh
quand on voit quand on voit des black
caillassés comme des MOMES euh des CRS
suréquipés, on reparlera juste après de
du business sécuritaire à côté de ça.
Euh quand on voit des black block euh
d'ailleurs avec les médias sociaux, on
les voit bien caillasser du flic comme
des momes parce qu'il faut appeler un
chat un chat. C'est ils sont
désorganisés, ils savent pas utiliser
les momes c'est les flics.
Non pas les flics, les mecs habillés
tout en noir là.
J'ai jamais vu des momes s'organiser
comme ça mais
bah c'est des mumes c'est
non c'est une forme de mobilisation
c'est une forme de c'est une forme de
contreattaque.
D'ailleurs, on l'a vu récemment même
chez les spécialistes dans la
gendarmerie, ils le disent he que c'est
de la manifestation professionnel de que
dal c'est ils se lancent des pavasses,
ils ont trois bouteilles à trois
machins, ils savent pas c'est de la guer
de gamin du 16e.
Je crois pas du tout. Ça c'est un
argument qui est mis en qui est mis en
avant régulièrement par exemple dans la
voiture brûlé
une vraie guerrie.
C'est pas des jeunes si c'était une
vraie guerria, il y aurait des morts.
Ça dépend chaque a pas de mort. Est-ce
qu'on a déjà vu ? Alors, j'ai entendu
sur j'ai entendu j'ai entendu sur une de
vos émissions, il y avait un flic en
face de vous qui vous disait "Oui, il y
a des il y a des grappins lancés contre
les flics." Moi, j'ai jamais vu un mec
les grappins, ça c'est quand c'est les
marins, c'est quand c'est les ouvriers
qui
Ouais, pour le mec qui disait ça dans l'
On a jamais vu, on a jamais vu
un flic se faire choper, se faire
séquestrer, foutu dans une cave avec une
caméra comme en Afghanistan, avec un
fling dans la bouche avec des
revendications précises. Donc nous quand
on voit les black lancer des petites
pavasses, est-ce que vous pensez que les
black blocks soient contre-productif
pour les luttes
? Mais c'est pas à moi de penser ça. Moi
je ce que j'observe c'est que le le
black block c'est une technique. Il y a
des mouvements sociaux se dotent de
technique face à la police dans la rue
quelle qu'elle soit. Les marins pêcheurs
et ben de temps en temps il il tirent au
au pistolet d'alerte sur la police. Les
sur les chantiers dans les années 80 et
ben ça balançait des boulons de 12 sur
les policiers. ce qui est beaucoup plus
dangereux que plein plein de choses. Euh
c'est des techniques. Euh la rue c'est
un c'est un espace de conflictualité et
on le voit, on l'a vu là récemment dans
des dans les conférences de de gendarmes
spécialisés dans ce domaineel. Les
gendarmes considèrent ça comme une
technique. Ils disent les black sont des
professionnels de l'émeut. C'est mais
c'est pas un but en soi. Moi je suis pas
là pour le défendre. C'est une technique
d'organisation comme dans les quartiers
populaires. Euh le Get à Pan, c'est une
technique de résistance, de
contre-attaque. Quand tu t'es fait
humilier, écraser euh pendant toute ton
adolescence, pendant régulièrement, et
ben de temps en temps, tu as envie de tu
as envie de montrer euh à l'unité qui
est euh chargée de ton quartier que bah
non, on va pas se laisser faire, que ah
ouais, si vous continuez à utiliser tel
type de brimade, d'humiliation, de
persécution, et ben nous aussi on peut
contre-attaquer. On n'est pas toujours
dans la position de la victime.
Ça fonctionne pas.
Bah je sais pas ce qui fonctionne en
fait. En tout cas, de rien faire et de
pas résister, ça fonctionne pas non
plus. Et c'est pas à moi, je sais pas
c'est à qui de dire ce qui fonctionne ou
pas.
Faut faut deux pour deux pour combattre.
Faut être deux pour combattre. Vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ou pas ?
C'est deux ennemis.
Il faut être deux personnes pour pour
combattre. Si une arrête de combattre,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Mais en fait vous vous reproduisez la la
fiction dont on parle depuis le début.
On n'est pas face à deux acteurs. Oui.
Oui. Mais on n'est pas face à deux
acteurs qui sont égaux. On est face à
d'un côté des forces qui sont euh un
appareil au service d'un état et d'une
société pyramidale qui sont surarmés,
suréquipé, qui bénéficient de budget
gigantesque euh face à des euh habitants
d'un quartier, face à des gens qui vont
lutter contre une loi, contre un contre
le la casse des services sociaux et
cetera. On n'est pas deux acteurs qui se
font la guéger euh h à l'école ou je
sais pas quoi. Euh il y a d'un côté le
peuple avec ces différentes euh
ces différentes fractions euh les
misérables d'un côté, différentes euh
fractions de classe sociale dans les
dans les mouvements sociaux où on
retrouve les black mais où c'est pas euh
forcément euh la jeunesse du 16e comme
ça a été dit et comme généralement dans
les médias c'est mis en avant comme pour
délégitimer ces formes de
contre-attaque.
Et ben de l'autre côté, on a des on a
des gens qui sont comme comme on l'a dit
avec des des budgets gigantesques qui
sont surprotégés, protégés par la
justice, protégés par des équipements,
protégés par les médias, protégés par la
classe politique. C'est pas deux acteurs
qui sont à égalité du tout. Et puis il y
en a qui d'un côté se battent pour
arrêter, je pense pour les quartiers
populaires, arrêter d'être opprimé
contre les contre les injustices, contre
les crimes policiers, contre la misère,
contre le racisme et cetera. Dans les
mouvements sociaux, ben on se bat contre
tel type de loi pour de l'émancipation,
pour de la justice sociale et cetera. Et
de l'autre côté, on a des gens qui sont
salariés, qui sont payés pour maintenir
un ordre social. Euh c'est pas deux
entités à égalité.
Est-ce que vous voyez des solutions ?
Bah oui, moi je appartiens au camp de
celles et ceux qui pensent que les
dominés peuvent s'auto-organiser,
peuvent créer des formes de vie
autonomes
comme les anarchistes
euh par exemple comme mais comme dans
dans toute l'histoire de l'humanité en
fait partout dans le monde des sociétés,
des peuples ont créé des formes de vie.
ou euh qui sont pas basés sur la
domination des uns par les autres, mais
sont basés plutôt sur la solidarité, sur
l'entraide, sur l'échange.
Ben bah là là en ce moment, il y a des
expérimentations au Tiapas par les
apathtistes, au Rojava par une partie
des des par une partie du peuple kurde.
On a dans
dans pas mal de régions en Afrique, en
Asie, en Amérique du Sud, en Amérique
centrale, en France aussi. en France
pendant à la fin du la fin du Moyen-Âge.
Et le la naissance du capitalisme, c'est
aussi une réaction euh face au fait que
il y avait des communes autonomes et des
communes libres euh qui
qui se laissaient pas faire et qui
résistaient au servage et qu'il fallait
passer à un nouveau mode pour les
pour les les classes qui profitaient de
ce système là. À cette époque-là, il a
fallu restructurer ce système là et donc
il a fallu écraser des formes de vie
autonomes qui existaient aussi. Et donc
là, il s'agit pas d'imaginer d'un
paradis avec des bisouss, mais
simplement des des formes de vie dans
lesquelles on s'exploite pas les uns les
autres, mais dans lesquelles on partage
la production, le travail. On partage le
travail au champ pour faire à bouffer
euh les services pour se rendre services
les uns les autres où on prend des
décisions tous ensemble en commun,
c'est-à-dire pas un gouvernement qu'on
est lit et qui fait ce qu'il veut, mais
plutôt des formes d'assemblée populaire,
des formes autogestionnaires, des
conseils d'habitants de quartiers, des
conseils de maison, des conseils de
village, des conseils de communes.
C'est pas un peu utopique tout ça dans
un contexte de guerre économique mondial
Ça dépend ce qu'on appelle l'utopie,
mais de de pour les républicains sous la
monarchie, la République c'était une
utopie. Et on leur disait "Taisez-vous,
c'est une utopie." Si c'est c'est une
utopie dans l'autre sens où ça nous
permet de réfléchir à ce qu'on veut
mettre en place de meilleur. C'est pas
une utopie dans le sens où ce serait
irréalisable parce que des formes de vie
comme ça, il en a existé partout, il en
existe et qu'elles sont combattues en
permanence justement par les systèmes de
domination parce que ça les menace
complètement. Une des choses communes à
tous les systèmes de domination, c'est
la mise en dépendance. C'est le fait de
casser les formes d'autonomie. Qu'on on
soit pas capable de produire sa propre
nourriture et qu'on soit obligé d'aller
au supermarché. Qu'on soit pas capable,
qu'on soit plus capable de se protéger
les uns les autres et quand il y a un
problème qu'on soit obligé d'appeler la
police au lieu de se réunir et de voir
comment on va pouvoir régler ça de
manière juste. Comment on va pouvoir
mettre en place une justice réparatrice
par exemple. Ça c'est des formes qui
s'expérimentent partout et qui menacent
ce système- là. Euh
business des prisons, c'est beau quand
même.
Le business des prisons aussi. Bien sûr.
2 minutes pour le business des prisons.
Bah ça fait partie de de ce système
économique et de sa transformation.
Ça repose sur les logiques de
ségrégation. C'est-à-dire qu'en même
temps que on attaque en permanence les
quartiers populaires et
qu'on tente de renforcer les formes de
de ségrégation de socioapartade, et ben
on enferme de plus en plus euh les
parties des classes populaires
généralement issues de la colonisation
aux États-Unis. C'est essentiellement
les noirs et les latinaux. Euh mais
quand on va dans les prisons françaises,
on trouve alors bien sûr essentiellement
des enfants de la classe ouvrière, mais
parmi ces enfants de la classe ouvrière
principalement des noirs, des arabes,
des asiatiques, des romes et cetera.
Enfin des des
pourqu pourquoi on trouve pas des
Portugais, des Espagnols ? Ça dépend des
époques, ça dépendah
aux époques où c'est les où c'est les
surexploités euh dans les dans les
premières vagues d'immigration, bah bien
sûr trouve on trouve des chasses dans le
nord il y a des il y a des chasses au
aux prolétaires belges. Dans le sud, il
y a des chasses enfin et policiers et
civils d'extrême droite qui chassent les
Italiens. On a des chasses au enfin des
des dans dans les bid les bidonvillees
de portugais contrairement à ce qui
avait été mis en montré dans les médias,
il y a pareil des formes de persécution
par les civils, par la police parce
qu'il s'agit d'écraser à chaque fois les
strates
les plus misérables mais aussi les moins
soumises des classes populaires
et que le le la coerstition, la brimade,
l'humiliation, ça sert à ça aussi, ça
sert à faire que les gens se tiennent
bien et la prison c'est un appareil se
tiennent bien pour le système et c'est
un appareil qui sert à ça, à dresser Il
y a pas beaucoup de chinois en prison en
France
discipliné. J'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas de
chiffres. Euh euh mais je pense que du
point enfin il faudrait voir les
proportions. Ça sert à rien de parler
dans l'absolu sans avoir de sans avoir
de chiffres.
Revenons aux solutions.
Mais juste je finis sur le l'industrie
carale. Donc c'est c'est à la fois un
appareil de dressage, de discipline,
d'écrasement,
d'éducation.
bah d'éducation, les les formes
d'éducation qu'on qu'on va pouvoir
rencontrer en prison, c'est pas le fait
de l'institution, c'est le fait de
résistance interne, de personnes qui
individuellement vont s'engager pour
aller transmettre des choses aux
prisonniers. C'est pas la logique de
l'institution carcérale de de d'éduquer
les classes populaires. Et donc on donc
on a on a cet aspect-là et on a un
aspect qui est un gigantesque marché, un
un marché pour on pourrait dire un des
marchés qui qui arrive au centre de de
du capitalisme actuel en en terme de de
d'infrastructure de d'encadrement de
bâtiment et cetera, mais de surveillance
aussi. Il y a énormément d'entreprises
de de de numérique de et de de contrôle
et de surveillance qui font un business
énorme sur toutes les nouvelles formes
d'incarcération. Donc je dis dans les
prisons, donc les les formes
pénitentiaires mais aussi les centres de
rétention euh les euh et les formes les
formes d'internement aux frontières. Euh
tout ceci c'est un marché gigantesque.
Renion camp de rétention administrative,
c'est ça ? Oui. centre de rétention
administrative euh et où du coup on
allonge les bon pour les pour les
centres de rétention euh les les durées
d'incarcération euh mais où en fait le
le le développement enfin le la
surenchère répressive d'un point de vue
euh législatif permet aussi de en
permanence de de continuer à construire
de nouvelles prisons qui se remplissent
automatiquement qui sont toutes en sur
en en surpopulation et presque ça fait
partie du dispositif he parce que ça
sert aussi à à écraser les formes de vie
cette surpopulation et ça génère un ça
génère à la fois un business pour les
entreprises qui participent au
fonctionnement de de ces institutions,
mais aussi parce qu'on fait travailler
les prisonniers en prison et que on a on
a les chiffres à fleuris,
on les fait pas travailler, on les
occupe. Oui, c'est ce qui c'est comme ça
que c'est justifié euh à Fleury et à Se
là, les derniers chiffres qu'on avait,
c'est ça tournait à peine plus de 1 € de
l'heure, c'est-à-dire des forme de
néoservage.
Il faut qu' bien qu'il se payent le PQ
qu'on leur on leur donne pas. Euh
voilà, c'est comme ça que c'est
justifié. Par exemple, la présidente là,
la présidente de la directrice, on
pourrait dire la PDG de la de la de la
maison d'Ar fleuri disait ça que c'était
pas un vrai travail, c'était pour les
occuper sauf qu'il travaille réellement
pour ça et qu'on a toute une série enfin
toute une série on a tout un système
économique qui vit grâce à ça.
Lursaf Lursef a pas son mot à dire
là-dedans,
je crois pas. Je sais pas. C'est
dommage.
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview, il nous reste environ 20
minutes. Euh
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur les
solutions, sur les pistes de solutions
pour vous.
Je disais des enfin c'est pas à moi de
les de les donner. Mais par contre, je
crois enfin j'appartiens au camp de
celles et ceux qui qui croient qui même
qui sont sûrs que les solutions, elles
sont chez les dominés, chez les
opprimés, elles et eux-mêmes et qu'elles
sont à inventer. Elles sont à inventé et
en même temps à récupérer dans des
formes qui ont déjà existé, on l'a dit,
la commune, les communes libres, les
communes autonomes et qu'elles sont
inventées aussi tout ensemble. ces
formes-là, elles sont il nous semble
qu'elles ont intérêt à creuser de du
côté de l'entraide, de la solidarité, du
partage, de forme de vie horizontale euh
et et joyeuse aussi.
Est-ce que est-ce que la violence c'est
une solution ?
C'est pas à moi de le dire. En tout cas,
historiquement, on voit que on n' jamais
vu des dominés et réussir à obtenir leur
libération en demandant gentiment à leur
maître. Ça, ça n'existe pas. Jamais des
dominants ont abandonné leur système de
privilège parce qu'on les aurait
convaincu avec des arguments. Ça
n'existe pas. Euh les
a est-ce qu'on a essayé ? Ah ben bien
sûr de tous les dominés commencent par
essayer parce que un système de
domination ça tient avec de
l'aménagement, de l'idéologie, du
divertissement et de la coercition. Tous
tous les systèmes de domination
et de la supportation
par exemple euh tous les dominés
commencent par euh parce que on on le
paye cher hein d'utiliser la violence ou
en tout cas et et la contre-attaque face
à un dominant. Tu le payes très cher et
tu le payes dans ta famille, dans ton
histoire. Donc les gens voient pas la
violence comme ça parce que ce serait
rigolo, parce que ce serait facile. Il y
a il y a pas de violence gratuite. Euh
c'est souvent en dernier recours, c'est
justement parce que les dominés ont tout
essayé et qu'il y a rien qui change, que
on le voit dans l'histoire des des
luttes d'émancipation anticoloniale.
pendant des décennies
les peuples essayent de d'aménager le
droit, essayent d'avoir des des formes
de des des des possibilités de vivre à
égalité avec avec les autres citoyens de
de la colonie et cetera et où en fait
après avoir essayé toute forme de
mobilisation et où à chaque fois on les
remet à leur place où à chaque fois on
les remet dans une situation d'être les
surexploités, les misérables, les sans
droit, euh on en les peuples enfin
redécouvrent sont obligés de réutiliser
de d'essayer des modes qui sont c'est
peut-être pas la question de la
violence, c'est la question de la force.
C'est qu'en fait l'émancipation
on te la donne pas, il faut l'arracher.
Vous connaissez action non violente ?
Quoi ? Le concept.
Le concept.
Oui.
Bah, il me semble que c'est c'est un
privilège l'action non violente. Si on
peut se libérer sans violence, tant
mieux. Enfin, je Tout le monde cherche
ça euh et tout le monde commence par
faire ça. C'est ce que je viens de dire.
Maintenant, si c'était facile de se
libérer euh
et si c'était possible sans violence, je
pense que ce serait fait depuis
longtemps. Mais moi, je dis pas qu'il
faut passer par la violence, je dis rien
du tout. Je constate simplement que
je dis force plus que plutôt que
violence, mais qu'en tout cas le la
violence, elle est du côté de la
structure des systèmes de domination.
Elle est la violence, elle est partout.
Elle est dans le racisme, dans le
travail, dans le sexisme, euh dans
toutes les formes d'exploitation, dans
elle est partout cette violence. Elle
elle est symbolique dans les médias,
elle est à tous les niveaux, elle est
elle existe en permanence. Et par contre
quand quand l'esclave, le colonisé, le
prolétaire
résiste, contre-attaque, tente de se
libérer, là bien sûr les formes qui met
en place, bien entendu, elles sont tout
le temps accusé d'être d'être violente.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la grève de
la fin ?
Ça me paraît
ça me paraît je je sais pas si j'ai
d'avis à donner dessus. Euh ça m'a ça
m'a toujours semblé
tellement dur de d'offrir à à son
adversaire le le spectacle de son corps
abîmé. Et en même temps, quand on
regarde encore une fois historiquement
qui est-ce qui qui en vient à utiliser
des méthodes comme ça ? C'est les
suroprimés. C'est toutes celles et ceux
qui ont utilisé tous les registres, tous
les régimes de résistance euh non
violente et cetera et qu'on écoute
jamais et euh et qui en viennent
finalement à essayer de au moins parce
que c'est pareil, c'est pas de l'ordre
de la force, mais d'interpeller euh
médiatiquement, mondialement différentes
instances en disant "Bah regardez, je
suis dans une situation d'injustice
telle que je suis prêt à mettre mon
corps en danger, voire en danger de
mort."
plutôt plutôt que d'apprendre un bouquin
de chimie par cœur et de lire les bons
bouquins pour éviter de lancer des
pavasse sur des CRS.
Je sais pas si c'est plutôt peut-être
que on pareil quand on regarde
historiquement, c'est plutôt des formes
qui vont remblent. Il y a des individus
qui qui utilisent ces formes-là pendant
que pendant que d'autres groupes
utilisent d'autres formes. Je sais pas.
En tout cas, c'est pas à moi de le juger
mais je le comprends.
Notredame des Landes, qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez ? La zone à défendre.
Je pense qu'il y a eu une je pense que
c'est une expérience
importante historiquement dans
l'histoire des des mouvements sociaux,
dans l'histoire des des luttes
d'émancipation et qui a
il y a notamment là-bas une chance de de
pouvoir
essayer de créer autre chose comme ça a
été dit là des formes de vie plus
joyeuses plus justes, plus solidaire.
Vous avez déjà été Notre Dame des Landes
?
Oui, j'y suis passé.
Vousz vous avez été où dans Notredame
des Landes ? J'étais dans différents
lieux. On a fait des ateliers de de
Quels étaient les lieux ?
Je sais plus les noms parce que j'ai été
Ça ressemblait à quoi l'intérieur ?
Bah moi, j'ai vu des gens qui justement
s'entraidaient, essayaient de
s'organiser avec les moyens du bord,
essayer de se respecter, essayer de
créer des formes de vie plus justes,
plus égalitaire. Ça marchait plus ou
moins parce qu'on est quand même
toujours dans cette sociétélà. Par
exemple, j'ai aussi vu des gens qui
mettaient en cause encore le fait que
bah par exemple que à l'intérieur de de
ces territoires là et ben il y avait on
pouvait encore subir des formes de
d'inégalité et qu'il fallait combattre à
l'intérieur que ça que parle le racisme,
le sexisme, tout ça, ça s'arrêtait pas à
la porte des milieux militants, à la
porte des territoires libérés. Mais j'ai
aussi vu des gens qui qui inventaient
d'autres formes de vie, des manières de
faire du pain gratuitement pour tout le
monde, de se trouver à manger, de le
partager. Le pain de la Zade, qu'est-ce
qu'il est bon.
De de prendre des décisions ensemble, de
faire ses propres médias.
Pourquoi il y a pas beaucoup de noirs à
la Zade mis à part trois souanis qui se
battent en duel ?
Il y a pas Bah ça, je pense pas que
c'est enfin je dirais pas comme ça. Il y
a il y a une minorité. Bah parce que je
pense que les les les personnes qui
subissent directement le racisme en
France, elles sont prises dans des
situations euh qui parfois les les
accrochent à la ville et pour le travail
euh et pour des appartences à des à de
la communauté d'entraide et cetera. Euh
par contre euh donc bien sûr c'est des
minorités euh mais c'est un c'est des
choses qui sont en cours. Il y a des
rencontres, il y a du volontarisme qui
est fait de la part de certains groupe
euh il y a des et il y a vraiment des
des rencontres et des choses qui se
construisent entre des habitants de
l'Azade et des habitants de d'Alnés
sous-Bois par exemple. Des rencontres
sur des objectifs, des objectifs de vie
en commun, des objectifs de libération
où les gens se sont rendus compte que
bah ouais qu'ils avaient des intérêts en
commun, qu' subissaient des dominations
en commun et qu'ils avaient tout intérêt
à se rencontrer. Euh voilà, je pense il
y a des il y a des choses qui cessaient.
Après euh aussi parce que une partie des
une partie des milieux qu'on dit
militants entre guillemets sont composés
de
aussi en partie de de classe moyenne et
que le et qu'une grande partie des des
personnes de couleur en France
appartiennent au aux classes populaires
voir aux sous-prolétariats et que des
fois il y a des ça prend plus de temps
pour se rencontrer et pour mettre en
commun des choses mais ça s'essaye et il
y a des choses qui émergent et il y a
des personnes sans papier qui trouvent
des du refuge à la zade qui trouve des
nouvelles formes de vie plus solidaire,
plus protégé euh
plus précaire, plus marginal, préca
avec des pathologies avec des
pathologies pour certains quartiers de
la Zade des mecs sacrément amochés parce
que ils dorment dans des conditions
je pense pas que ce soit la Zade qui
produit ça. plutôt la société dans
laquelle on vit. Et après les gens les
gens font ce qu'ils veulent. S'ils vont
s'ils vont à s'ils vont à la Zade en je
sais pas combien il y a de kilomètres de
Nant enfin c'est qu'à un moment ils y
trouvent quelque chose qui leur permet
de de survivre un peu mieux sinon ils y
pas. Et
ouais ou plutôt garder leur dignité dans
la forêt.
C'est bon
être acteur de sa vie. On va retourner à
la zad être juste victime d'un système
mais aussi d'être
on retourne à la suet. On retourne à la
Zade. On vous emmène
euh
pour faire une un petit une petite
sociologie sur place.
Non, moi je j'étudie pas les j'étudie
pas les luttes, j'étudie pas les
dominés, je j'y participe à la rigueur.
Si on m'invite là-bas pour y faire des
choses avec des gens, pour participer,
pour construire ensemble, j'irai j'irai
le cœur ouvert, mais j'irai pas pour
étudier ou pour regarder. C'est pas le
zo
non, je suis entièrement d'accord. C'est
pas le zo mais il y a un accueil là-bas
qui est chaleureux
exactement
dans toutes les factions de la zade
c'est-àd que même les pires marginaux de
la Zade qu'on a présenté comme des
alcooliques
et ils nous ont su à 10h du matin au
réveil les bras ouverts sans savoir qui
on était
et puis il y a aussi plein de paysans.
Il y a plein de il y a des paysans
alcooliques aussi je pense. Il y a des
C'est vrai. C'est vrai.
Et puis toutes les pathologies toutes
les g toutes les
Ouais. des pathologies de surinfection
sur une jambe chez le paysan général la
MSA il laisse pas tomber
et oui mais ça tombe pas du ciel aussi
c'est ça c'est souvent le c'est le
produit de de galère dans des parcours
de vie
quand ils sont tapés dessus par les
flics. Question d'internet. Parlons du
business de la sécurité en France. On
vend beaucoup d'armes point
d'interrogation à des dictatures. Est-ce
que on va vers les milices privé ? Donc
il y a trois questions dans une.
Oui, on va alors le le secteur de
l'armement est un des un des piliers de
l'économie française avec le avec le
avec bah le le nucléaire.
[Musique]
la vente à des dictatures mais en fait à
toutes sortes de régimes. C'est pas tant
c'est pas c'est pas que le le complexe
mito industriel français
ambitionne principalement les
dictatures, c'est qui vend à tout à tout
régime qui a de l'argent et qui est prêt
à lui en acheter. Et aussi mais c'est
vrai que
on vend pas la Corée du Nord.
On vend pas la Corée du Nord non. Euh
mais bon, en tout cas, les des des
régimes dictatoriaux qui même par
exemple peuvent être pas forcément ultra
solvables, c'est intéressant parce qu'on
peut mettre en place des régimes de
dette un régime de dette, bon ça va
rapporter plus d'argent dans l'avenir,
mais c'est aussi c'est un régime de
soumission sur la longue durée. Euh euh
bon voilà.
Euh donc oui, le la France-Afrique est
notamment un système de réseau officiel
et officieux dans lesquels le business
de la défense et de la sécurité est
central. Et la troisème question c'était
est-ce qu'on va faire les milices
privées alors ça ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle milice mais par contre le
développement de bon alors la s la
sécurité privée c'est un marché pareil
fondamental dans le développement moi ce
que j'appelle le capitalisme sécuritaire
qu'on voit émerger dans toutes les
grandes puissances occidentales où le
droit les États aménagent le droit pour
donner le plus en plus de possibilités
de développement aux entreprises qui
font de la sécurité privée dans tous les
domaines he pas juste technologique et
industriel mais aussi par exemple pour
pouvoir pouvoir intervenir
à côté ou en remplacement de force de
police
étatique. Ça donc ça c'est déjà des
formes qui sont en place à différents
niveaux. Je veux dire par exemple
sous-traitance de du déplacement des
détenus des choses comme ça. Aux
États-Unis c'est bien plus avancé le
lacération des mineurs. Il y a eu
quelques scandales là-dessus. C'était
scan aussi pour des juges qui se sont
fait attraper au bout de 20 20 ou 30
ans. Ils mettaient tous les gamins en
prison pour faire fonctionner le
business. Ça c'est c'est vraiment bien
documenté.
Exactement. Ouais. Le le laboratoire
principal de tout ça, c'est le
mercenariat privé mais qui est pas une
nouveauté en fait qui est plutôt quelque
chose d'historique et même qu' enfin à
toutes les époques. On a trouvé qu' a
été contenu pendant un certain moment
par les par les États occidentaux pour
pour des raisons sur lesquelles on on
pourrait revenir et que là effectivement
on a vu remonter en puissance l'utilisé
de l'utilisation d'armée privée. Donc
bon, notamment par les États-Unis he on
connaît les les histoires de Black Water
et cetera. Euh c'est des choses qui sont
en train de s'aménager dans le droit euh
européen euh notamment pour faire
sous-traiter euh l'occupation euh on
parle du Sahel enfin en particulier mais
les les différents territoires
néocolonisés de les faire sous-traiter
par euh par des par des forces privées.
Et ben et encore une fois, il y a il y a
une logique de retour à l'intérieur où
on sent bien que c'est à la fois un
marché énorme le développement de la
sécurité privée et donc même de d'unité
de police privée. Et en même temps qu'un
marché, c'est une logique de rentabilité
du contrôle. Et donc là, on n'est pas
dans l'ordre tellement de des milices,
enfin ou sens de milices civiles euh et
où là on a effectivement le le système
sécuritaire cherche énormément à
développer des formes de participation
des populations civiles au contrôle.
Alors donc ça va du voisins vigilants à
là récemment, on a eu les les chasseurs
vigilants qui sont autorisés, je crois
que c'est dans dans la drôme,
à accompagner la police, enfin à faire
le travail.
C'est ça, non ? Auxiliaire de
renseignement. Voilà. Ouais, c'est comme
ça que ça a été dit. Donc
ça, je suis plus sûr.
Non, si si c'est ça, c'est le terme qui
a été utilisé. Euh, on a je crois que
c'est un c'est à Nice. Euh, bon des
nouvelles applications pour les sur les
téléphones qui viennent de de
d'entreprise israéliennes qui permettent
du coup à des civils de filmer d'autres
civils et d'envoyer directement les
vidéos en les taguant euh aux centrales
de police. Et donc bah pour faire le
pareil du travail de renseignement, de
dénonciation et cetera. Euh
Oh là là ! C'est vrai,
on a vu passer ça.
On a vu passer ça.
Vous l'avez vu ?
Ouais. On a vu passer ce trucl là.
Imaginez ça à Vichi à la belle époque.
Non mais c'est des dispositifs qu'on
voit. C'est pas un hasard si on voit on
voit pas mal de de dispositif.
Ma grand-mère se retourne dans sa tombe.
Désolé pour la parté. H Et mais
effectivement le le le sécuritaire
avance avec l'identitaire. toute on a
toute une série de formes des nouvelles
formes de contrôle qui sont liées à la
montée en puissance des idéologies
nationalistes identitaire d'extrême
droite. Ça va ensemble. C'est pas du
tout encore une fois une bavure ou des
excès du système, ça va directement avec
le système et c'est plutôt les classes
dominantes qui utilisent en permanence
l'extrême droite comme une sorte de
réservoir réservoir d'idées et de
pratique. On laisse exister voir on la
met on l'aide à monter en puissance.
Extrême gauche aussi. Non,
je je connais pas de d'exemple de
dispositif d'idées d'extrême gauche qui
soient récupéré par les par les par la
bourgeoisie pour pour améliorer ces ces
formes de gouvernement de la population.
Euh mais du coup dans ces formes de dans
les formes que choisit le sécuritaire,
il y a ces logiques de désignation de
l'ennemi intérieur euh ethnicisé, racisé
parce que ça permet de diviser les
classes populaires, de diviser euh les
les résistances, de diviser pour mieux
régner et en même temps, il y a vraiment
une logique de rationalité,
d'optimisation du contrôle parce qu'en
faisant participer des dominés à leur
propre encadrement, ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher et puis ben ça met de l'huile
dans les rouages et ça c'est vraiment
une des logiques C'est des des analyses
que je défends au long de mon travail.
Une des logiques des sociétés de
contrôle du système sécuritaire, c'est
de favoriser le développement des formes
de sous-traitance, de participation à
l'encadrement, à la surveillance, au
contrôle. Et je pense que c'est des
choses qu'on retrouve à tous les niveaux
des sociétés, dans les domaines qui vous
intéressent aussi.
L'intelligence artificielle, ça vous
fait penser à quoi avec votre secteur
d'activité ? Ah bah euh
si on conjugue votre secteur d'activité
et l'intelligence artificielle
euh je sais pas exactement où tu veux en
venir mais en tout cas moi je
l'intelligence artificielle je l'observe
vraiment c'est un des grands secteurs
euh de la recherche et développement
dans le dans les technologies de
surveillance euh de traitement des
données, big data et cetera, mais aussi
qui va qui bouleverse hein les le les
formes panoptiques euh les les formes de
de surveillance partout où on a de on a
de la caméra partout maintenant de qui
va aller de l'uniforme policier
à au téléphone du civil, à les les aux
formes de de reconnaissance des identité
génomique, de cartographie des systèmes
veineux et cetera et où partout on
trouve l'intelligence artificielle.
Voilà. Après, comme sur le reste, je
pense que c'est une des choses dont il
faut se parler, c'est des dispositifs de
pouvoir. Et les dispositifs de pouvoir,
comme dans toutes les époques, dans
toutes les les les périodes historiques,
euh c'est des mécanismes, ça bug, ça
dysfonctionne, ça se sabote, ça
fonctionne jamais comme euh celui qui
l'a conçu après a prévu que ça
fonctionne. Ça toujours, ça se réagence
en fonction de résistance populaire. Il
y a pas de forme de domination absolue
euh dans le camp de concentration euh
sur la plantation esclavagiste et cetera
où on a voulu créer des formes de
pouvoir total et ben on a vu des formes
de résistance naître, des créativités,
des formes de fuite, des formes de
contre-attaque. Il y a toujours une
intelligence des dominés qui réussissent
à se rencontrer, à trouver des moyens de
discuter, à trouver des moyens de
partager leurs idées pour for fabriquer
des formes d'intelligence collective qui
vont inventer euh de la nouveauté. Et le
pouvoir cherche en permanence hein, à
aller puiser dans la créativité des
résistances. Et chez les hackurs, on le
voit régulièrement, toutes les toutes
les firmes et toutes les polices du
monde cherchent à embaucher des jeunes
hackers et et à les retourner parce que
justement ils savent très bien que dans
la dans la dans la résistance, dans la
créativité du crocheter euh il y a il y
a il y a il y a du enfin il y a de la il
y a de la possibilité de créer des
nouveaux dispositifs de serrure. Et ça
c'est une dialectique permanente, la
serrure et le crocheteur. Et il y aura
jamais meilleur concepteur de serrure
que qu'un génie du crochetage.
Tout ça je le dis pourquoi ? Je dis
justement pour pas qu'on tombe dans des
formes de pessimisme de a big brother,
l'état total partout parce que ça c'est
le fantasme et c'est la fiction qui
essaie de mettre en avant justement
cette industrie de sécurité de faire
croire qu'elle elle produit des
technologies et des dispositifs qui sont
capables de contrôle total et de
domination totale.
Et je pense que jusqu qu'on nous
apporter les formes de résistance, même
les microrésistances
qui existent partout et tout le temps,
c'est justement cette forme d'espoir de
voir que les les gens se laissent pas
faire et que le et qu'il y a des formes
d'intelligence collective qui permettent
de créer en permanence des formes
d'évitement, des formes de et que la
colère aussi les ça existe toujours et
dans la colère et dans la contre-attaque
bah il y a de l'espoir et dans l'espoir
il y a la manière de créer d'autres
formes de vie et c'est sûrement dans ces
enje ces gens ces enjeuxl qu'il Il faut
investir, jamais jamais perdre de vue.
Résister, c'est créer. Créer, c'est
résister.
Question d'Internet. L'invité pense-t-il
qu'une société pourrait pourrait
fonctionner sans forme de police pour
interrogation ou critique-t-il la
modalité de celle-ci ?
Euh les deux. Euh je critique les
modalités de celle-ci. Enfin, je la
chaque société a la police qu'elle
mérite. Euh donc, on a des polices
racistes, sexistes, féroces parce qu'on
est dans une société capitaliste,
raciste, sexiste, néocoloniale et
cetera.
Et du coup, je pense que quand on aura
réussi à créer des sociétés débarrassées
des rapports de domination, euh on
inventera d'autres choses mais que ça
servira à rien d'appeler police parce
que ce sera plus que là on appelle la
police aujourd'hui. Et alors jeis dire
et pourtant euh euh au chapas zapatistes
euh s'expérimentent, je je donne cet
exemple-là parce que eux ils utilise le
forme le le terme de police
communautaire, ce qui du coup pourrait
un peu gênant du point de vue de
l'analyse que je défends. Mais c'est
effectivement de de point de vue de
cette analyse là, c'est pas de la police
qu' produisent. Ils produisent donc on a
des des villages, des communautés
auto-organisées qui décident ensemble
des manières dont elles veulent vivre et
bien entendu elles se font attaquer par
le par le narcoétat par le narcoétat
paramilitaire qui leur envoie des
assassins euh des dealers des violeurs
et cetera. Et donc il faut bien se
défendre et puis que bien sûr chaque
société a toujours ses formes de de je
sais pas comment dire de de
de ces problèmes à l'intérieur des des
injustices des des gens qui vont se
taper dessus des qui enfin qu'il faut et
qu'il faut qu'il faut régler. Bon ben
là-bas, on travaille plutôt sur la
question de la justice réparatrice. On
essaie de voir euh entre tous les gens
qui ont été concernés par une injustice
ou par une ou par une une exaction pour
voir comment on peut réparer ça. Et puis
on met en place des groupes. Euh ça ça
dépend des communautés hein, mais on met
en place des groupes qui vont être
chargés euh de
participer à résoudre les conflits et à
trouver des formes justes socialement.
Alors, ces groupes des fois, ils
arrivent et ils commencent par euh
expliquer euh ce qui s'est dit à la
dernière assemblée populaire pour faire
savoir ce qui s'y est dit, à trouver des
solutions ensemble et cetera. Ils
appellent ça de la police communautaire.
Moi, du point de vue de l'analyse que je
défends euh ce serait justement pas de
la police, c'est déjà autre chose. Et du
coup, je crois que des sociétés libres
et autonomes et émancipées que qu'on
organisera devront enfin devront vont se
doter de formes euh qui permettent de
lutter contre euh euh contre des
violences internes, contre des conflits,
des injustices euh d'un point de vue
réparateur, pas d'un point de vue
punitif, disciplinaire
et cetera et c effectivement des choses
à à inventer.
Question d'Internet, quel est quel est
son avis ? Donc le vôtre, hein, quel est
son avis sur l'évolution de l'État de
droit en France et en Europe ?
Je pense que l'état de droit, ça fait
partie des fictions
qui servent à faire fonctionner ce
système- là parce qu'en vérité, enfin,
on peut passer son temps à dire "Ah,
l'état de droit, c'est la fin de l'état
de droit, l'état d'urgence permanent qui
rentre dans la constitution et cetera."
En fait, c'est pareil si on regarde
historiquement, enfin tous les ans, on
crie à la fin de l'état de droit. Et en
réalité, qui est-ce qui a des droits
dans une société pyramidale ? Bah, c'est
les riches qui ont le droit de faire
tous les business qu'ils veulent, légaux
et illégaux. On le voit dans toutes les
affaires politiques. Euh c'est les le
système la la culture du viol et le
système patriarcal qui donne le droit
aux hommes de faire ce qu'ils veulent
sur le corps des femmes, des minorités
sexuelles et cetera. Bon, pour moi, dans
une société pyramidale, dans une société
capitaliste, autoritaire,
le droit, c'est pas quelque chose qui
est horizontal, c'est pas quelque chose
qui est partagé. Et puis qui est-ce qui
fait régner le droit ? C'est de d'où
viennent les le le la classe sociale qui
fait exister le droit,
qui fait les lois,
qui fait les lois, qui les applique, les
juges, juges, magistrats et cetera. D'où
ils viennent ces gens-là ? Je pense
qu'on pourrait, on en trouverait pas
beaucoup de gens qui viennent de des
classes ouvrières, des classes
populaires dedans. Et c'est pas un
hasard. C'est pas pour dire qu'il faut
mettre des ouvriers euh à l'Assemblée
nationale ou ou dans les ou dans les
tribunaux. J'y crois pas trop. Enfin, je
je pense qu'il se transformerait
rapidement le le pouvoir euh corrom.
Absolument.
On va voir ça avec Ruffin.
Euh on arrive à la fin euh de notre
interview.
On a pour habitude de demander à nos
invités de laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations. Ah, une dernière
connexion pardon dernière dernière
question internet
pour les origines de la police pour
l'interrogation 1600 combien ? 1626
non il y en a plusieurs du coup il y a
les condés ça vient d'où les condés ? il
y a sous 14. Donc on a la on a le
concept général de police qui lui vient
vient organiser le marché. En gros, on
est on est face aux premières aux
premières émeutes euh enfin pas aux
premières mais à des émeutes de la fin
qui sont liées, ce qu'on considère à
l'époque, à une mauvaise gestion du
marché, le marché où on s'échange les
marchandises. Et donc, on a cette
histoire là d'un côté où la police
émerge pour encadrer le marché
réellement. Et c'est ce qui va donner
jusqu'à aujourd'hui, hein. La police est
là pour protéger maintenant le marché au
sens au sens capitaliste.
Et dans les pratiques, un des grands
laboratoires euh ça va être la
plantation esclavagiste et la colonie
euh notamment à travers des milices euh
civiles et privées de chasse aux
esclaves fugitifs où on va autoriser euh
des
esclavagistes à former des unités de des
milices pour chasser les esclaves en
fuite et on va on va leur donner tous
les droits de punition, de meurtre et
cetera et que c'est dans ces formes-là
qu'on va importer des dispositifs euh
dans la première dans les premières
justices, des formes de justice et
d'organisation des règlements de police
dans les dans les décennies qui vont
suivre. Donc là encore, on a une forme
de rencontre entre le laboratoire
de l'accumulation capitaliste et le
laboratoire de de l'écrasement colonial.
Alors, notre dernière question, un
conseil, c'est même pas une question,
c'est une une injonction. Laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer.
Bah ou même pour les vieux.
Ouais.
C'est pareil. Moi, je suis pas trop du
genre à donner des conseils, mais je
fais partie de celles et ceux qui
pensent qu'on a on a raison d'avoir de
l'espoir parce que il y a de la
résistance de partout et que et qu'il
faut les nourrir ces résistances et à
tous les niveaux, dans tous les
domaines, dans toutes les formes de vie
et que et qu'on a raison aussi d'essayer
de développer des formes de vie joyeuses
et de solidarité, créer des liens, créer
des ponts entre tous les dominés, entre
toutes les opprimés, exploiter des
formes d'entraide, de rencontre, créer
des lieux de vie en commun et créer des
moyens des moyens pour que chacune et
chacun puisse s'emparer de sa propre
résistance, de sa propre libération.
C'est pas à nous d'aller libérer les
autres. Par contre, on peut tenter de
fabriquer des lieux et de mettre à
disposition des moyens pour que chacune
et chacun puisse fabriquer sa
libération. Des centres sociaux
autogérés, des centres de santé
communautaire,
des centres de formation des au hacking
gratuit dans les quartiers populaires
des et cetera et cetera. euh des lieux
et des moyens dans lesquels on peut
partager euh nos expériences euh et où
on peut euh créer de l'intelligence
collective et mettre en commun nos
envies de nos envies de de vivre euh et
de nous libérer.
Un livre et un philosophe à conseiller ?
Plein euh
au moins trois
trois livres, trois philosophes.
Bah si en a plein, il faut envoyer trois
sur trois. trois philosophes, trois
livres et on se dépêche
euh là comme ça, je dirais euh euh
la férocité blanche, ça c'est une
contre-histoire enfin une histoire de de
tous les génocides oubliés. Euh
euh on peut surveiller et punir de Fouo
et
lire Gramchi et Marx, je pense que c'est
pas mal. Lire Angela Davis,
ouais, ça fait déjà quelques références.
Matur Gust merci.
Ben merci de m'avoir donné un peu la
parole d'avoir discuté. Merci bien.
Coupez.
[Musique]